Let me ask you something, Red. Yeah? How did we get into this? Well, bare judgment would be the most general explanation. It was just, in certain stages it seemed a natural thing to do. Because other people I knew were doing it and seemed to enjoy it. Yeah, well nobody where I was at when I got interested in the subject was doing it, I can tell you. I was over in the damn Pacific War.
让我问你一件事，雷德。怎么了？我们是怎么卷进这件事的？嗯，最笼统的解释就是纯粹的判断。在某些阶段，这似乎是一件很自然的事情。因为我认识的其他人在做这件事，而且看起来很享受。是的，但我开始对这个主题感兴趣时，我周围的人可没人在做这个，我可以告诉你。我当时在太平洋战争中。
But I had an anthology of poetry that some girl sent me. And I think my whole orientation in my life and my career and work and everything else changed on the use of one word and one poem. It was about the carpe diem theme seize the day live while you can and it was especially poignant to some young soldier i was 20 21 years old over the damn pacific who was fixing to get killed almost every day and that especially in my case every night of the war and i read it and it's the lines were apollo springing naked to the, and all his island shivered into flowers. I thought, my God, isn't that wonderful? Shivered? Now, who shivered into flowers?
但我有一本诗集，是一个女孩寄给我的。我想我的人生观、职业生涯、工作以及其他一切，都因为一首诗里的一个词而改变了。那是关于“及时行乐”的主题，活在当下，趁你还能活的时候去生活。对于一个当时在太平洋战场上，几乎每天、在我的情况下是战争期间的每个夜晚都随时可能丧命的20、21岁的年轻士兵来说，这尤其令人心酸。我读到了它，诗句是：“阿波罗赤身跃向……他所有的岛屿都战栗着化作了花朵。”我想，天哪，这难道不美妙吗？战栗？那么，是谁战栗着化作了花朵？
What an image. I mean, it's like this. I mean, you can see the movement of the delicate shaking of the flowers, living things that are perfectly beautiful and perfectly mindless. And all these islands shivered, shivered into flowers. I thought, this is for me. I must see what I can do. Hey guys, this is Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective Podcast, and welcome to part four of Healing the Modern Soul.
多么美的意象。我的意思是，就像这样。我的意思是，你可以看到花朵那种细腻颤动的动态，这些活生生的事物既完美又美丽，且完全无意识。而所有这些岛屿都战栗着，战栗着化作了花朵。我想，这就是我要找的。我必须看看我能做些什么。嘿，大家好，我是Taproot Therapy Collective播客的乔尔，欢迎收听《治愈现代灵魂》的第四部分。
If you've made it this far, I'm not going to do too much of a preamble here. The clip at the beginning will be explained a little bit at the end, but not too much. And let's get going. So we have a subjective experience that we live within. But it is constantly communicating with an outer world through necessities of thought and action and concept. And the inner world is immediate and it is implicit and it is filled with things like curiosity and gut reaction and warm feelings and icky aversions and unknowing unknowing without holding knowledge and it can't talk it can only feel like a baby that is gumming the carpet on its tummy. If I'm a mom that just gave you, I mean, not if I'm a mom, if you were a mom and I just
如果你已经听到了这里，我就不多做开场白了。开头的片段会在结尾稍作解释，但不会太多。让我们开始吧。我们生活在一个主观体验中。但它通过思想、行动和概念的必要性，不断地与外部世界进行交流。内心世界是直接的、隐含的，充满了好奇心、直觉反应、温暖的感觉、令人不适的厌恶感以及无知——那种没有知识储备的无知。它无法言说，只能像一个趴在毯子上用牙龈磨着地毯的婴儿那样去感受。如果我是一个刚给你……我的意思是，不是如果我是妈妈，如果你是妈妈，而我刚刚
gave you an icky feeling, imagine the baby is on a blanket, gumming the blanket until it starts to cry. And that's what the subjective world's experience is like. And there is also this outer world that is material and it is cold and it is distant. And we have to learn to survive within that. And it cares about things like taxes and genetic predisposition and prison walls and retirement and cancer. And imagined ego immortality. And neither the world, neither world can quite touch the other one, but sometimes we pretend they can and they feel like they can touch each other. And maybe they can sometimes in ways that
给了你一种不舒服的感觉，想象一下婴儿在毯子上，用牙龈磨着毯子直到哭出来。这就是主观世界的体验。还有一个外部世界，它是物质的，是冰冷的，是疏离的。我们必须学会在其中生存。它关心的是税收、基因倾向、监狱围墙、退休和癌症。还有想象中的自我永恒。这两个世界谁也无法真正触及对方，但有时我们假装它们可以，它们感觉好像可以触及彼此。也许在某些我们尚未理解的方式下，它们确实可以。但尽管它们是分离的，无法真正触及，它们却通过脑干、楔前叶和前额叶皮层纠缠在一起。你知道，古老的和现代的、被遗忘的和未被铭记的力量都在嚎叫和尖叫，渴望被喂养，渴望成为中心，渴望哪怕只是一分钟成为自我。而自我是一个不断收缩、环绕、遮蔽和亏缺的东西，我们记住它，又忘记它，我们抓住它，又放下它。也许这就是为什么，你知道，反义词能如此好地描述自我。也许反义词是唯一能真正描述它的东西。或者我只是个很糟糕的诗人。你知道，就像高中时有人第一次抽大麻。他们会说，也许一切皆虚无。也许大即是小。或者当……
we don't even understand yet. But even though they're separate and they can't quite touch, they are entangled together across this brainstem through the precuneus and the prefrontal cortex. You know, ancient and modern forgotten and unremembered forces are all howling and screaming to be fed and to be made center and to be made self for just a minute. And the self is this constantly shrinking and orbiting and eclipsing and waning thing that we remember and we forget and we hold and we put down. And maybe that is why, you know, antonyms describe the self so well. Maybe antonyms are the only thing that can really describe it. Or maybe I'm just a really bad poet. You know, it's like the first time that somebody at your high school smokes weed. They're like, maybe everything is nothing. Maybe big is small. Or when...
所以也许情况就是这样。但关于自我，真正混乱的部分在于，外面还有其他人，他们也有自我。我们必须把这种混乱揉进伴侣关系、家庭和社会中。然后我们该怎么办？你知道我们是怎么走到这一步的？所以，美国政治趋势之所以很难谈论，嗯，是因为没有单一事件。我说的“难谈论”不是指你会惹上麻烦，而是指很难谈论，因为关于每一件事，比如，越战之后，大多数美国人第一次在历史上报告说这个国家不再是地球上最好的国家之一，或者他们的生活不会像70年代他们的父母那样，还有卡特和奥纳伯格。所有这些事情从一个角度看总是相关的，但从另一个角度看
So maybe that's the case. But here's the really messy part about the self is that there are also other people out there with selves too. And we have to smush this mess up into couples and families and societies. and then what do we do you know how did we get here so one of the reasons that trends in american politics are kind of hard to talk about um is that there's no event and i don't mean hard to talk about like you get in trouble i mean hard to talk about like everything, everything you say about, like, well, after the Vietnam War, most Americans reported for the first time in history that this country was not one of the best countries on earth, or that their life would not be the same as their parents during the 70s, and Carter and Ornaburger. All those things are constantly relevant from one angle, and also
又不相关。美国文化中没有哪一个事件是单子的，或者，嗯，无论一个事件从我们的历史视角来看多么重要，当你研究另一种力量或另一群人时，它也是不重要的。因为从来没有单一的事情在发生，任何重大的事情都是美国政治或文化中许多力量共同作用的结果。因此，任何关于社会文化和历史转折点的视角，不可避免地，不可避免地会对其他任何大型群体无关紧要。或者它会在不同的人群中引发矛盾的情绪反应，说，不，
not relevant from another angle. There's no like one event in American culture that is monadic or, um, no, no matter how important one event seems from our historical perspective, it is also unimportant when you're studying another force or another group of people. And because there's never just one thing going on, anything big that happens as a culmination of like lots of forces together in American politics or culture. And so like any perspective on a cultural and historical hinge point in society will inevitably, inevitably it will be irrelevant to any other large group. Or it'll evoke a contradictory emotional response and in a different demographic that says, no,
那是事情开始变糟的时候。50年代比60年代好。一个例子可能是肯尼迪遇刺，大多数美国人会将其视为一件大事、一个转折点，或者事情发生改变的地方，即使他们说不出，嗯，就是那个统计数据，人们说他们不再信任政府，
that's when things were getting bad. The 50s is better than the 60s. One example might be something like the Kennedy assassination, which is something most Americans would point to as a big deal or a hinge point or a place where things just change, even if they can't say, well, it was the statistic where people said that they no longer trusted the government,
或者后来加上尼克松。即使不是那样，也是那种感觉，在那之后美国对我来说变得不同了，那种感觉在很多人身上都在发生，所以即使他们没有把它看作是一个他们不知道自己参与其中的统计数据，他们都说，是的，就是在那时变得不同了，你知道，嗯，但假设你看看非裔美国人，嗯，他们是一个你知道，嗯，但假设你看看非裔美国人，嗯，他们是一个你知道，确实因为识字测试、人头税、暴力、恐吓和祖父条款而被剥夺了投票权的人群，这些条款，嗯，真的是一件疯狂的事情，他们无法投票，你知道，在56年的选举中，我想大约25%左右的非裔美国选民参与了，更多，我想大约是30%或40%，你知道，对于
or then combined with Nixon. Even if it's not that it's that the feeling of america was different after that for me and that feeling was happening in lots of people so even if they weren't looking at it as a statistic that they didn't know they were a part of they all said yeah that's when it was different you know um but say you look at african americans um who were a demographic that you know um but say you look at african-americans um who were a demographic that you know had really been obstructed from voting with literacy tests and poll taxes and violence and intimidation and grandfather clauses which um are a really insane thing and they couldn't vote you know in the 56 election i think like 25 percent or something of african-american voters even participated and more i think it was like 30 or 40 you know for
肯尼迪遇刺或肯尼迪的选举，嗯，你知道，更多人参与了，但从某种角度来看，那不是他们的总统，就像，嗯，很多非裔美国人并不觉得，我的意思是，很多……我不是在以偏概全。我是说这就是为什么这些问题很复杂。如果你觉得你的政府官员不代表你，或者他们不是我的代表，你知道，就像你没有代表我，或者你是选举过程的一部分，
the kennedy assassination or for kennedy's election which um you know more people participated but it wasn't their president from a certain perspective like um a lot of people that were african-american didn't feel like i mean a lot of dead i'm African American didn't feel like, I mean, a lot of did. I'm not painting with too broad a brush. I'm saying that this is why these are complicated. If you didn't feel like your government officials represented you or they weren't my representative, you know, like you're not representing me or you're part of an electoral process
而我被排除在外，你可能对你的选票不重要，或者有人剥夺了你的选票，或者，你知道，无论那是什么，都不会有同样的反应。这只是一个例子。我的意思是，我不是想深入探讨肯尼迪，但是，你知道，这种国家如何看待自身以及哪些自我部分是相关的自我形象的转变。你知道，总有人跳出来说，不，不，不，我们做历史研究的方法错了，因为我们需要从这个角度来看，说，实际上，那篇文章一直都是这样写的，而且还会继续写下去。而且它永远不会完全是错的。
that I've been excluded from, you may not feel the same reaction to your vote not mattering or somebody taking your vote away or, you know, whatever that is. And this is just one example. I mean, I'm not trying to go too far into Kennedy, but, you know, that shifting self-image of how this country perceives itself and what parts of self are relevant. You know, somebody's always popping up and saying, no, no, no, we're doing history wrong because we need to look at it from this angle and say, actually, that article's always been written and it will continue to be. And it can never quite be wrong.
自我的不同部分是相同的。它们对彼此以及对方的相关性有不同的看法，它们总是为了争夺驾驶权而斗争。而且，你知道，个人和文明内部的自我，并不是一个固定不变的实体，而是一个动态的、不断变化的景观，由不断转换的力量和部分连接的力量在争夺表达和压抑的过程中塑造。在这个试图寻找某种平衡的过程中，哪怕只是一分钟。我在这里画了一个平行线，指向我在开头描述的自我感、自我感觉，以及我们创造国家历史的方式，因为它们是相似的。心理治疗本身的历史可以被看作是一个文明，你知道，作为一个整体，在进行关于什么是自我的对话。因为，你知道，就像我在上一期谈到的，你，你对自我的概念对于你如何构想什么是心理治疗、它的目标是什么、你知道，人与谁接触、他们是什么，是内在相关的，对于一个旨在，一，接触他们，二，对他们做点什么的模式来说，你知道。我在第一、二、三部分中已经论证过，你知道，这个系列的一部分是我们可以观察心理治疗的流派和学派，我们可以，
Different parts of self are the same. They have different opinions about one another and each other's relevance, and they're always sort of fighting to see who could drive the car. And, you know, self within an individual and a civilization, it's not a fixed and immutable entity, but it's a dynamic and ever-changing landscape that's shaped by constant transitioning of forces and partially connected forces fighting for expression and repression. In this process of trying to partially connected forces fighting for expression and repression in this process of trying to find something like equilibrium for just a minute. I'm drawing a parallel there to the sense of self, the sensation of self I described in the
你知道，能够从中读出关于我们文明的东西。我们可以收集它的直觉、恐惧、神经症和精神病，随着治疗的变化。心理治疗学派之间经常有战争，而且确实有战争。很多东西真是太搞笑了，伙计。就像我记得很久以前的一次会议，我希望有这段视频，但就像有一次会议，萨尔瓦多·米纽钦（Salvatore Mnuchin），他是家庭治疗专家，嗯，或者他们都是家庭治疗专家，但米纽钦是结构派的。他说，抛弃所有的情绪。不要问他们感觉如何。
beginning, and the way that we make history of a country because they are similar. And the history of psychotherapy itself can be seen as a civilization, you know, as a whole having a conversation about what self is. Because, you know, like I talked about in the last one, you sort of, your concept of self is integral to every part of how you are conceiving of what psychotherapy is, what its goals are, you know, who the person is in contact with, what they are is inherently relevant to a model that is supposed to be one, contacting them and two, doing something to them, you know. And I've argued in the first one, two, and three, you know, part of this series that we can look at movements and schools of psychotherapy and we can,
不要看那些。不要告诉他们要相爱。只要画一张家庭图，说爸爸妈妈靠得太近了，把孩子排挤在外。我想这通常不会是个问题。妈妈和孩子靠得太近，因为和父亲之间有紧张关系，这里有纠缠，这里有三角关系，然后打破这种结构，用那种方式修复它。你知道，他是结构派家庭治疗师。而约翰逊（Johnson）则完全专注于情绪聚焦疗法，认为你应该只进入情绪，不要担心诊断，不要担心分析。他们，就像，在同一次会议上发言，说着完全相反的事情，然后回答问题。
you know, be able to read things about our civilization from those. We can glean its intuitions and its fears and its neuroses and its psychoses as therapy changed. Often wars between schools of psychotherapy and there are wars. A lot of stuff is just so funny, man. Like I remember a conference conference long time ago, I hope there's a video of this, but there's like a conference where Salvatore Mnuchin, who's like the family therapy guy, um, or they're both family therapy people, but Mnuchin was like the structural person. He was like, throw out all of emotion. Don't ask them how they feel.
观众感到不舒服，而且，就像，他们每个人都在互相投射这种目光。而且，你知道，这不仅仅是弗洛伊德派和荣格派，他们得到了很多关注，就像还有很多治疗师互相憎恨，我总是觉得这很有趣，因为它太搞笑了，但这正是因为这个东西，因为自我，你知道，就像你可以看到，你知道，在精神分析研究所的早期破裂中，你知道，美国和英国，你知道，他们在80年代转向认知疗法，但你知道，弗洛伊德和阿德勒，他们为这种深度导向的心理治疗奠定了基础，它强调了潜意识的重要性，
Don't look at any of that. Don't tell them to love each other. Just draw a diagram of the family and say the mom and dad are too close together and it's excluding the child. I guess that wouldn't normally be a problem. The mom and the child are too close together because there's tension with the father and there's enmeshment here and here's the triangulation and then bust up the structure and fix it that way. You know, he's a structural family guy. And Johnson was all about emotion-focused therapy and that you should only just go into the emotion and don't worry about diagnosis, don't worry about analysis. And they're, like, presenting at the same conference at one point and they're saying, like, the complete opposite thing and then responding to questions.
心灵以及象征和原型维度，而且你知道，弗洛伊德的自我被分为这三个部分：本我、自我、超我。每一个都在情感和行为中扮演了角色。然后荣格说，不，你知道，有一个集体潜意识，有一些我们共享的东西，是某种神秘的东西。我知道它在那里，因为我能感觉到它。当我与我的病人交谈时，他们也知道这种体验，即使我们没有经历过，它也是某种与生俱来的东西。但它不仅仅是我的。它不仅仅是我作为婴儿时如何与母亲个体化，或者，你知道，作为婴儿经历了孵化阶段的压抑。它更深，更古老。它出现在神话中。当我读历史时，我能认出它。
And the audience is uncomfortable and, like, each of them are shooting these glances at each other. And, you know, it's like it's not just the freudians and the unions which get like a lot of ink like there's just people who are therapists that hate each other and i always just got such a kick out of that because it's so funny but it's because of this thing it's because of self you know and like you can see you know in the early ruptures of the psychoanalytic institutes where you know the american and the uk you know they pivot towards cognitive therapy in the 80s but you know freud and adler they laid this foundation for this depth-oriented psychotherapy and it emphasized the importance of the unconscious
你知道，弗洛伊德想把历史作为性压抑来分析，但他并不真的想认同它。他试图将自己与历史分离，将自己与人类学分离。弗洛伊德想统治所有这些东西，他的治疗模式有点像是在出卖自己。你知道，我不认为这是描述弗洛伊德心理学的一个坏模式。我认为试图将其应用于其他人有点牵强。而且你知道，随着治疗的发展，20世纪，人们越来越强调开发更具经验性和快速的技术，你知道，我们如何更快地进行精神分析，因为所有这些
mind and symbolic and archetypal dimensions and you know freud the self was divided into these three components id ego superego Each of those played this role in feelings and behaviors. And then Jung said, no, you know, there's a collective unconscious and there's something that we share that is kind of mystical. And I know it's there because I can feel it. And when I talk to my patients, they also know this experience, even though we haven't lived it, it's sort of inborn. But it isn't just mine. It isn't just my repression of how I individuated from my mom as a baby or, you know, went through this hatching stage as a baby. It's deeper. It's older. It shows up in myths. I can recognize it when I read history.
有钱人浪费了这么多钱和时间，嗯，你知道，付钱给弗洛伊德和荣格进行精神分析，因为它极其昂贵，呃，你知道，我们如何更快地在更广泛的临床环境中应用它？于是你有了格式塔疗法、Hakomi和声音对话。所有这些开启这些模式的个人都在试图让某人以不同的方式意识到这种内在的自我体验。并以一种，你知道，更全面和实验性的方式整合自我的不同方面，有时就像人本主义心理学运动，卡尔·罗杰斯和亚伯拉罕·马斯洛，他们，马斯洛，就像他们强调自我实现的重要性，以及对一种更
You know, Freud wanted to psychoanalyze history as this repression of sexuality, but he didn't really want to identify with it. He was trying to separate himself from history, separate himself from anthropology. Freud wanted to dominate all of those things and his model of therapy was kind of telling on himself. You know, I don't think it's a bad model for describing Freud's psychology. I think it's a stretch to try and apply it to other people. And you know, as therapy evolved, 20th century, there's this growing emphasis on developing more empirical and rapid techniques you know how do we do psychoanalysis faster because all these
全面和以人为本的治疗方法的需求。他们看到人们，看待人们本身，而不是治疗模式，而是人以及他们创造意义的方式更重要。这其中有一种存在主义的倾向。它被一种新时代的、神圣的特质所调和，但它更具存在主义色彩，即我想看看你想如何创造意义，而不是我如何创造意义，然后我教你如何做。同样，60年代和70年代有这种超个人心理学运动，试图将自我的边界扩展到个人自我之外，去探索，你知道，精神和超越的维度。也许自我不是来自这里。
rich people wasted all this money and all this time um you know paying freud and jung for psychoanalysis because it was incredibly expensive uh you know how do we apply a wider range of clinical settings quicker? And you get gestalt therapy and Hakomi and voice dialogue. And all of these individuals that start these modalities are trying to get somebody to be aware of this internal experience of self in a different way. And to integrate different aspects of self in a you know more holistic and experimental way sometimes and like the humanistic psychology movement was carl rogers and abraham maslow and they maslow like they emphasize this important of self-actualization and the need for a more
也许它甚至不是我的生活。也许它是，我当时想，我在亚特兰蒂斯就认识你，这就是为什么我知道你有一个治疗师。也许自我是在时间之外的。你得到了一种宇宙学和物理学的，你知道，对自我的解构，比什么都大。而且，你知道，斯坦尼斯拉夫·格罗夫（Stanislav Grof）和肯，你知道，肯·威尔伯（Ken Wilber），就像他们主张这种更综合和全面的自我观，可以涵盖个人和超个人。所以你不必只做那种奇怪的水晶吟唱精神活动。你可以像在个人之前那样摇摆，这是我此时此刻的生活。是的，我要冥想亚特兰蒂斯什么的。
holistic and person-centered approach to therapy. They saw people seeing people for who they were and not the model of therapy as much, but the person and the way that they were making meaning is more important. There was sort of an existential bent to that. It was tempered with a new age, numinous quality, but it was more existential in that I want to see how you want to make meaning, not how I make meaning, and then I show you how to do that. And similarly, there's this transpersonal psychology movement in the 60s and 70s that was trying to expand the boundaries of self beyond individual ego and to explore, you know, spiritual and transcendent dimensions. Maybe the self didn't come from here.
因为70年代的人在治疗中很想做这些，嗯，你可能写了很多糟糕的诗，里面有很多反义词，如果你明白我的意思的话。他们，但你可以与你内心那个感觉比星星还古老、超维度的部分坐在一起，但同时也意识到你需要起床开车送孩子上学，而且你和家人之间还有些事情要解决。因为我认为那些人和后来的一些综合治疗师，他们认为新时代运动有点逃避现实，确实如此。其中一个对此理解做出贡献的关键人物是阿蒂·兰（Artie Lange）。兰是一个反精神病学的人。
Maybe it's not even my life. Maybe it's, I was like, I knew you on Atlantis and that's why I knew that you had a therapist. Maybe the self is outside of time. You get a cosmological and physical, you know, deconstruction of self that's bigger than whatever. And, you know, Stanislav Grof and Ken, you know, Ken Wilber, like they were arguing for this more integrative and comprehensive view of self that could encompass both personal and transpersonal. So you didn't have to just do kind of weird crystal chanting spiritual stuff. You could sort of oscillate before a personal, this is my life here right now. Yeah, I am going to meditate on Atlantis and whatever.
我不喜欢他所做的一切，但其中一些真的很棒。他所说的一件事就是连接本身就是治愈。你知道，他会教他的学生，他自己也做，但我读到的那个叙述来自一个学生，她当时就觉得，这永远不会奏效。有一位患有精神分裂症的女士，她在尖叫，拔自己的头发。我想她拉在自己身上了，她扔了床垫或者把床垫撕开了。研究生当时就想，嗯，我不能进去。
Because people in the 70s wanted to do that in therapy a lot um you probably had a lot of bad poetry that they were writing that had a lot of antonyms in it if you know what i mean and they but you could sit with the trans dimensional part of yourself that felt like it was older than the stars but then also realized that you needed to get up and drive the kids to school and that you had some stuff to work out with your family. Because I think those guys and some of those integrative therapists later, they saw the New Age movement as a little bit avoidant, which it was. And one of those key figures who contributed to this understanding that is interesting was Artie Lange. And Lange was an anti-psychiatry guy.
而他说，不，你必须和这个人在一起，直到他们好转。慢慢地，最初待在那个混乱的房间里对学生来说太不知所措了。然后她意识到，哦，我正在适应。我正在调节。我进入了她那个混乱的领域，这个细胞，现在我能够冷静下来了，然后她意识到那个人冷静下来了，然后他们开始交谈，你知道，而且她，这花了一个星期，就像，我的意思是，我想她在里面待了几天，我的意思是，这是狂野西部，呃，再也不能在研究生院那样做了，呃，呃，或者在心理学领域广泛地，但是，嗯，据称
I don't love everything that he did, but some of it is really neat. And one of the things that he said is just the connection is healing. You know, he would have, he would taught his students, he did himself too, but the account that I read was from a student and she was just like, this will never work. And there was a lady who had schizophrenia and she was screaming and pulling her hair out. And I think she had defecated on herself and she threw the mattress or ripped the mattress up. And the graduate student was like, well, I can't go in here.
那个人能够对药物做出反应，并且能够回来，你知道，从他们所在的任何地方。嗯，就像这么多这些，呃，RD兰，你可能，如果你，我说的每一件事，你可能都没听说过，但如果你在学校听说过他，那就是“空、钝、砰”（empty, dull, thud），就像他是那个人，嗯，但他不是做“空、钝、砰”实验的那个人，那是罗森汉（Rosenhan），但他们是这个反精神病学运动的一部分，我没有任何证据，但我，我肯定，你知道，在那个世界的潮流中，就像当兰在1960年写《分裂的自我》（The Divided Self），然后罗森汉在73年做那个实验，而兰在1970年用他的煽动闹事制造了巨大的噪音，那些运动是
And he was like, no, you have to be with this person until they're better. And slowly just being in the chaos of that room at first was so overwhelming to the student. And then she realized, oh, I'm getting used to it. I'm regulating. I entered her sphere that was chaotic this cell and now i'm able to calm down and then she realized the person was calm and then they were talking you know and and she and it took like a week like i mean i think she was in there for days i mean it was this was wild west uh never could do that in grad school again uh uh, or in psychology broadly, but, um, supposedly the
在一起的，他们知道彼此，他在影响那个，而且，你知道，当罗森汉做这个实验时，那个实验，如果你不熟悉它，就是，你知道，他们说，好吧，精神科医生，你们说你们有一种别人没有的神奇能力，可以只和某人交谈然后诊断他们，对吧？所以我们要让我们的研究生，我们的研究生要进入一家医院。他们只是要说，我没有任何症状，但我听到“空、钝、砰”。我只是听到一个声音说“空、钝、砰”。在实验的某些版本中，我想他们只是说“砰”。但我读这个已经是高中时候的事了。但这就是他们所做的。
person was able to respond to medication and was able to come back, you know, from wherever they were. Um, and like so many of these, uh, RD Lang, you probably, if you, everything I'm saying, you probably haven't heard of, but if you heard of him in school it was the empty doll thud like he was that guy um but he wasn't the one that did the empty doll thud experiment that was rosenhan but they were part of this anti-psychiatry movement and i don't have any evidence for it but i'm i'm sure you know in the in the waters of that world like when lang writes the divided self in 1960 and then rosenhan does that experiment in 73, and Lang's making a ton of noise in 1970 with, like, his rabble rousing, that those movements are
精神科医生说，好吧，你得了精神分裂症。他们说，我不认为我有那个。我没有任何其他症状。他们说，不，你得了精神分裂症。我们是精神科医生。我们知道我们是对的。他们被关了几个星期。他们。我们知道我们是对的。而且，他们被关了几个星期。他们不知道什么时候能出来，他们无法说服任何人
together, they knew about each other, he's influencing that, and, you know, by the time Rosenhan makes this experiment, and that experiment, if you're not familiar with it, was that, you know, they said, okay, psychiatrists, you guys say that you have this magical ability that no one else has to just talk to somebody and then diagnose them, right? So we're going to get our graduate school students, and our graduate school students are going to go into a hospital. And they're just going to say, I don't have any symptoms at all, but I hear empty, dull thought. I just hear a voice that says empty, dull, thud. And in some versions of the experiment, I think they just said thud. But it's been a minute since I read this one in high school. But that's all they did.
他们没病，他们没病，因为他们是常春藤盟校撒谎的研究生，嗯，是在做实验，而不是我们在撒谎。他们在做科学。所以，嗯，那些，这使得整个“你把医学变成了压迫者”的想法。好家伙。你只是说你有一种特殊的力量。那是魔法，但你实际上没有。医学界开始变得如此医学化和硬科学，有很多原因，而嗯，心理学是一门软科学，我们说让我们稍微用一下你的直觉，现在你让我们尴尬了，你知道，现在我们
And the psychiatrist said, okay, you've got schizophrenia. And they're like, I don't think I have that. I don't have any other symptoms. And they're like, no, you've got schizophrenia. We're psychiatrists. We know that we're right. And they get committed for weeks. They. We know that we're right. And the, the, they get committed for weeks. They don't know when they're getting out and they can't convince anyone that
要有一个筛选器，如果你勾选这些框，它会告诉你你有什么。精神科医生只是经验导向测试的执行者，这些测试告诉我们你是否抑郁。告诉我们你是否有精神分裂症。告诉我们你的自我出了什么问题。你认为什么并不重要。这就是运动远离以人为本的治疗的时候。以一种它相当彻底地远离的方式。真的直到现在。有阻力，事情在改变。
they're not sick and they're not sick because they're graduate school students that are lying from Ivy leagues, um, are doing an experiment rather than we're lying. They were doing science. So, um, those that makes this whole idea of like, you're turning medicine into the oppressor. Good dude. You're just saying you have a special power. It's magic, but you don't actually. There's a ton of why the medical establishment starts to get so medical and hard science and with um psychology is it's a soft science we said let's use your intuition a little bit now you've embarrassed us you know and now we're
兰的工作在使治疗政治化方面非常有影响力。我认为这就是为什么会有这种阻力，说，不，这是经验性的，不是政治性的。滚出去。带着这种政治、激进和参与性的文化力量可以进来分析这个职业的想法滚出去。这是数字，这是无聊的。反主流文化与企业之间的这种斗争
going to have a screener where if you check these boxes it will tell you what you have the psychiatrist is just the administer of empirically derived tests that tell us if you're depressed or not. That tell us if you have schizophrenia. That tells us what is wrong with yourself. It doesn't really matter what you think as much. And that's when the movement moves away from person-centered therapy. In a way that it pretty hard moves away from. Really until now. There's pushback and things changing.
以及很大程度上某种军事、富有等等，所有这些60年代的权力斗争，里面也有很多种族问题，嗯，它结束了，因为那些是观点，而这是一门科学，所以他的想法以一种我认为他不会喜欢的方式产生了共鸣。反主流文化，他点燃了他们。然后这激怒了医学界，将任何那种思维的途径从职业中推出去，或者让任何把治疗变成极其政治化项目的人成为异类，他们仍然有点像。你知道，有非常右翼和左翼的人上新闻谈论
And Lange's work was really influential in making therapy political. And I think that's why there was this pushback to say, no, this is empirical, it is not political. Get out of here. Get out of here with this idea that a political and an activist and an engaged cultural force can come in and analyze this profession. It is numbers, it is boring. This struggle that the counterculture is having with the corporate
无论什么，但他们通常是影响者而不是治疗师。所以这种更具社会和政治参与性的心理治疗愿景消失了。所有那些超个人和人本主义，我的意思是，像弗吉尼亚·萨提亚（Virginia Satir）这样的人在录音带里谈论他们将如何改变整个世界，人们将治愈创伤，创伤治愈将传播出去，你作为病人将学习如何进行遭遇小组，你将无意中成为一名治疗师，并且有一种滚雪球的反应。这不仅是一个政治项目，对他们来说。这几乎是，特别是格式塔疗法，其中一些东西试图让治疗几乎成为一种人本主义宗教，你知道，人本主义对这些人来说是一种宗教，人类潜能运动是试图将人本主义变成一种宗教
and largely kind of military wealthy whatever every all these power struggles in the 60s there's a lot of racial things in there too um it's out over because that those are opinions and this is a science um and so his ideas resonated in not a way I think he would like. The counterculture, he fired them up. And then that fired the medical establishment up to push any avenues for that kind of thinking out of the profession or to make anybody who made therapy an incredibly political project an outlier, which they still kind of are. You know, there's very right-wing and left- wing people that go on the news and talk
而这一切都被推开了，因为那个短暂的时刻，嗯，经济衰退，社会的重组。卡特发表了“信心危机”演讲，说，也许你认为美国是的那种神话是错误的，或者它不再可能了。还有这次石油禁运，我们需要思考美国的新神话可以是什么，你能参与我的这个项目吗？每个人都说不，我们讨厌“信心危机”演讲，我们不喜欢这个，我们拒绝放弃我们对这种生活领域应该是什么的想法，然后石油又变便宜了，所以他们真的不必了。而且因为，就像，石油禁运中的很多人，他们不认为石油会回来。
about whatever, but they're usually more influencers than therapists. And so this vision of like a more socially and politically engaged psychotherapy goes away. All of that transpersonal and human is, I mean, people like Virginia Satir are on tape talking about how they're going to change the entire world, that people are going to heal trauma and the trauma healing is going to go out and you're going to learn as a patient how to have an encounter group and you're going to inadvertently become a healer and there's a snowball reaction. This was a political, not just a political project for them. It was almost, especially with gestalt therapy some of these things were trying to make therapy almost be a humanistic religion you know humanism was a religion to these people the human potential movement is an attempt to turn humanism into a religion
我的意思是，如果你去过佛罗里达州的Seaside，如果你去过30A，对吧？这是一个地方，我不知道你是否有国际听众，但它与新城市主义有关。它与这种关于重新以行人、社区为中心、摆脱汽车的建筑运动有关。这些都是好主意。这些设计运动仍然非常受欢迎。但它们存在的原因是因为莱昂·克里尔（Leon Krier）和许多指导像杜安尼（Duany）这样的人的建筑师，他们后来创造了这些运动，他们就像，我们要在70年代沿着风线设计城镇。我们要建造这些像1920年代的，嗯，你知道，美国城镇，那里
and that is all pushed out because that i brief moment um there's an economic recession, a restructuring of society. Carter gives the crisis of confidence speech and says, maybe the myth that you think that America is is wrong or it's not possible anymore. And this oil embargo, we need to think about what the new myth of america can be can you engage me in this project and everyone says no we hate the crisis of confidence speech we don't like this we refuse to give up our idea of what this sphere of life is supposed to be and then oil got cheaper again so they didn't really have to and because, like, a lot of people in the oil embargo, they didn't think that the oil was going to come back.
有穿过步行街的自行车道，汽车是事后才想到的，因为他们认为社会可能看起来时间之箭会逆转，二战后出现的石油繁荣和后工业化会回到它原来的地方。人们真的认为这会发生。显然没有。石油变便宜了。1980年代发生了。罗纳德·里根发生了。玛格丽特·撒切尔在英国发生了。当这种情况发生时，这是一个个人主义的时代。不仅是美国作为自制国家的神话，它偏离了欧洲并创造了自己的未来，现在它必须去清理欧洲在世界大战中的烂摊子，不仅那个消失了，嗯，不仅没消失，不仅那个以一种你知道卡特当时有点回应的方式回来了
I mean, if you've been to Seaside, Florida, if you've been to 30A, right? It's a place, I don't know if you've got international listeners, but it's associated with new urbanism. It's associated with this architectural movement about recentering things about pedestrians, community, getting rid of the car. And those are good ideas. And those design movements are still really popular. But the reason they existed is because Leon Krier and a lot of those architects that mentored the people like Duany, who went on to make those movements were like, we're going to design towns along wind lines in the 70s. We're going to build these like 1920s um you know american towns where
整个危机，通过说也许我们应该想知道我们是谁，每个人都说不，我们知道我们是谁，我们不仅是我们过去的样子，我们甚至比我们过去的样子更像我们过去的样子，狂野西部的神话回来了，它不仅是个人和国家，它是个人，并且有一种市场驱动的社会和政治生活方式，你说你知道，当然它是在促进政府问责和效率的幌子下。我们必须私有化它。所以里根和撒切尔说，有一种社会愿景，国家的作用应该被废除，以支持私营企业和个人责任。我们要通过运行所有这些，你知道，经验测试来看看你是否应得你得到的钱，只有治疗率超过80%的医院才能得到任何东西，你
there's crisscrossing bike lanes through pedestrian streets and like the car is an afterthought and because they thought that society may look the arrow of time would reverse and this boom of oil and post-industrialization that came after world war ii would just kind of go back where it was. And people really thought that that would happen. Obviously it didn't. Oil got cheaper. The 1980s happened. Ronald Reagan happens. Margaret Thatcher happens in the UK. And when that happens, there's this era of individualism. Not only is the myth of America as the self-made country that diverged from europe and made its own future and now it has to go clean up europe's messes and world wars like not only is that gone um not only not gone not only is that back in a way that you know carter was kind of responding to the
知道，当然这从来没有奏效，你知道发生的事情是人们开始只是说，哦，你想让我们治疗80%的病人，现在我们要改变“治疗”的定义，意味着他们在候诊室，字面上，字面上，字面上，这在英国发生了。你只是改变定义，达到指标。它从来不是为了奖励好人，摆脱坏人。这是因为你想削减资金，然后你这样做是为了表现得好像，嗯，他们应得的。无论如何，这接管了一切，它撕碎了这个愿景。这对社区层面的心理健康是有害的
whole crisis by being like maybe we should wonder who we are and everyone says no we know who we are not only are we um what we used to be we're even more of what we used to be than we used to be we're the the myth of the wild west is back it is not just individual and and uh country it is individual people and there's this market-driven approach to social and political life where you say you know and, and of course it's under the guise of promoting government accountability and efficiency. We've got to privatize it. So Reagan and Thatcher say there's this vision of society where the role of the state is to be gotten rid of in favor of private enterprise and individual responsibility. and we're going to do that by running all of these you know empirical tests to see if you deserve the money you're getting only the hospitals that treat above 80 percent will get anything you
因为你削减了资金并拆除了所有这些社区心理健康项目和机构，其中一些自20年代以来就辛苦建立起来了。很多自新政以来，但其中一些甚至比那更古老。而那种社区基础设施，当你削减资金时，就消失了。如果你看电影《小丑》，那就是其中一些甚至比那更古老。而那种社区基础设施，当你削减资金时，就消失了。嗯，如果你看电影《小丑》，你知道，这就是关于什么的。这就是
know of course this doesn't ever work you know what happens is that people start just saying oh you want us to treat 80 of patients well now we're going to change the definition of treat to mean that they're in the waiting room literally Literally, literally that happened in the UK. And you just change the definition, meet the metric. It never really is to try and reward a good guy and get rid of a bad guy. It's because you want to defund things and then you do it to act like, well, they deserve it. And anyway, that takes over and it rips this vision up. And it's damaging to mental health at the community level
在他电影开头发生的事情，你听社会工作者说话，她看起来像是坏人。然后慢慢地她就像，不，看，你以为我是坏人。这比这糟糕得多，你知道，我别无选择。而那，这就是正在发生的事情，他的社区心理健康的东西正在被关闭。而且，你知道，取代这种基于社区的方法，这种新的，你知道，日益严重的非常新自由主义的自由市场自由放任秩序说，我们想要个性化、医学化的心理健康。这意味着我们必须使用精神药理学和行为。我们不
because you defunded and you dismantled all of this community-based mental health programs and institutions that had been painstakingly built, some of them since the 20s. A lot of it since the New Deal, but some of it was even older than that. And that community infrastructure, when you defunded it, is gone. If you see the movie Joker, that's of it was even older than that. And that community infrastructure, when you defunded it is gone. Um, if you see the movie Joker, you know, that's what it's about. That's what's
真的想让你再谈论妈妈了。我们只想告诉你，如果你这样做，那是坏的。如果你这样做，那是好的。如果你在做我们告诉你是好的事情，而不做我们告诉你是坏的事情时遇到困难，我们要给你药物。这是以不同程度的成功完成的。我意识到这对某些人有效。这对很多人来说感觉非常非人性化和令人不安。但这就是日益严重的1980年后，就像每个人都要用英国的公共选择、英国的私人选择或美国的私人选择来支付的东西。当你这样做时，这就成了大多数提供者所做的，因为他们拿钱，你知道，生活，他们会去钱所在的地方。所以，你知道，这些方法是短期的，它们提供，你知道，缓解，对于一些
happening to him in the beginning of the movie, where you listening to the social worker and she seems like she is the bad guy. And then slowly she's like, no, look, you think I'm the bad guy. It's way worse than this, you know, and I don't have any choice. And that that's what's happening is his community, community mental health thing is being shut down. And, you know, and I don't have any choice. And that's what's happening is his community mental health thing is being shut down. And, you know, in place of this community-based approach, this new kind of, you know, increasingly very neoliberal free market laissez-faire order said we want individualized, medicalized mental health. And that means that we have to use psychopharmacology and behavior. We don't
人，但它们往往无法触及心理学曾经接触过的潜在社会和政治因素。所以，你知道，对于弗洛伊德、荣格、阿德勒和珀尔斯（Perls），你知道，这一整代人和他们之后的一代人，治疗不是一个政治项目，我不认为，对他们来说，但它是一种向权力说真话的方式。这是一种成为挑战现状的世界推动者和震撼者的方式。而在这一时期，治疗进入了现状的口袋，以一种它仍然没有从中分离出来的方式。而且，你知道，难以衡量的一件事是，这些事情中的很多，你所做的是你让症状下降
really want you to talk about mom anymore. We just want to tell you, if you do this, it's bad. If you do this, it's good. And if you're having trouble doing the thing that we told you was good and not doing the thing we told you was bad, we're going to give you drugs. And this is done with varying degrees of success. I realize this works for some people. It felt very dehumanizing and upsetting to a whole lot of other people. But that's increasingly circa post-1980, like what everybody was going to pay for with the public options in the U.K., the private options in the U.K., or the private options in the U.S. And when you do that, that becomes what most providers do because they take money to, you know, live and they're going to go where the money is. And so, you know, these approaches are short term and they provide, you know, relief for some
到医院衡量的方式。哦，好吧。好吧，现在我们要把候诊室重新定义为在床上接受治疗的病人。现在我们100%的病人都接受了治疗。请不要削减我们的资金，以同样的方式发生。治疗开始变成这种“鸡生蛋，蛋生鸡”的事情，或者不是鸡生蛋，就像豆壳游戏，豆子在壳下，对吧？你在移动它。所以你在说，哦，不，它不在这里了。它在这里。但你正在把可能导致某人喝酒或做一些不健康事情的焦虑拿走。然后你只是，你没有说，为什么会有那种焦虑？心灵在做什么？它在补偿什么？你只是说，把它放在这里。如果你不能把它放在那里，我们会给你药物，而
people, but they often fail to get at underlying social and political factors that psychology used to be in touch with. And so, you know, for Freud and for Jung and for Adler and for Perls, you know, this whole generation of people and the generation after them, therapy wasn't a political project, I don't think, for them, but it was a way to speak truth to power. It was a way to kind of be movers and shakers of the world that were challenging the status quo. And in this period, therapy moves into the pocket of the status quo in a way that it still hasn't separated itself from. And like, one of the things that is hard to measure is that a ton of these things, what you're doing is you're making the symptom go
人们，但他们往往无法触及心理学曾经接触过的潜在社会和政治因素。所以，你知道，对于弗洛伊德、荣格、阿德勒和珀尔斯来说，你知道，这一整代人以及他们之后的一代人，我认为治疗对他们来说并不是一个政治项目，但它是一种向权力说真话的方式。这是一种成为挑战现状的世界推动者和变革者的方式。在这一时期，治疗以一种至今仍未与之分离的方式进入了现状的口袋。而且，难以衡量的事情之一是，这些事情中有大量是你正在让症状消失
down to the same way the hospital's measured. Oh, okay. Well now we're going to redefine a waiting room as a patient who's been treated in a bed. And now a hundred percent of our patients have been treated. Please don't cut our funding in the same way that that happens. Therapy starts to become this chicken and the egg thing or not chicken and egg, like the shell game where the pea is under the shell, right? And you're moving it around. And so you're saying, oh, no, it's not here anymore. It's here. But you're taking anxiety that may be causing somebody to drink or do something that is not healthy. And then you're just, you're not saying, why is that anxiety there? What is the psyche doing? What is it compensating for? You're just saying, put it over here. And if you can't put it over there, we'll give you medication and the
就像医院衡量的那样。哦，好吧。现在我们要把候诊室重新定义为已经在床上接受治疗的病人。现在我们百分之百的病人已经接受了治疗。请不要像那样削减我们的资金。治疗开始变成这种先有鸡还是先有蛋的事情，或者不是先有鸡还是先有蛋，就像豆子在壳下的骗局，对吧？你在移动它。所以你在说，哦，不，它不在这里了。它在这里。但你正在把可能导致某人酗酒或做一些不健康事情的焦虑拿走。然后你只是，你没有说，为什么会有那种焦虑？心灵在做什么？它在补偿什么？你只是说，把它放在这里。如果你不能把它放在那里，我们会给你药物，然后
medication will change that for you. And it will lower that anxiety. And you're not looking at, when you only look at the symptom, you lose the rest of the self. And so like people like Lange in the anti-psychiatry movement, which in a lot of places were crazy and wrong. I'm not defending any of these people entirely. But I think when someone has good ideas that move the world that are relevant to history, it was this important challenge to that dominant individualistic metaclass paradigm that won. And in the 70s, one of the things that we like sort of lost in therapy, and I also think it's one of the reasons why like medical healthcare and I don't mean empiricism is bad. I mean, empirical only, the only things you can measure are the only things you allow in psychology, which is going to be behavior in certain limited kinds of cognition,
药物会为你改变这一点。它会降低那种焦虑。当你只关注症状时，你就失去了自我的其余部分。所以像反精神病学运动中的兰恩（Lange）这类人，他们在很多地方是疯狂且错误的。我并不是完全在为这些人辩护。但我认为，当某人拥有推动世界发展且与历史相关的优秀思想时，这对当时占主导地位的个人主义元阶级范式构成了重要的挑战，而那种范式最终胜出了。在70年代，我们在治疗中失去了一些东西，我也认为这是医疗保健（我指的不是经验主义不好，而是指仅凭经验主义，即只有你能测量的事物才被允许进入心理学，这局限于行为和某些有限的认知）的原因之一，
very, very top level, very, very explicit cognition. When you do that, you lose the subjective experience and these abstract realms of consciousness that people were exploring in the 70s. And to a certain extent, I think that the LSD, psilocybin, whatever, got so weird, that everyone as a whole kind of woke up and said, what did we do? When the money ran out in the 70s, when the party was over, those people lost so much credibility. A lot of them were drug addicts. A lot of them had made all of these supernatural almost promises about
非常、非常顶层的，非常、非常明确的认知。当你这样做时，你就失去了主观体验以及人们在70年代探索的那些抽象的意识领域。在某种程度上，我认为LSD、裸盖菇素等等变得太离谱了，以至于每个人作为一个整体都醒悟过来，说：我们做了什么？当70年代资金耗尽，当派对结束时，那些人失去了太多的信誉。他们中很多人是吸毒者。他们中很多人做出了几乎超自然的承诺，关于
this coming eon and epoch and what was going to happen. And all of those were kind of panning out to be like hokum. And so it was pretty easy for everybody to say oh we never believed in any of that i mean of course the dod was paying for it they were giving people lsd and putting uh you know twins together in different rooms and seeing if they could read each other's minds and having people stare at farm animals to see if they could mentally kill them with telepathy i mean no one really knew you know google uh what's his name? John C. Lilly. Google, uh, Lilly's dolphin experiments. I mean, that, that was all DOD money. Um, so when people realize like, oh my gosh, feeding LSD to this dolphin doesn't actually let me talk to God. That was
即将到来的永世和纪元，以及将会发生什么。所有这些最终都被证明是胡言乱语。所以每个人都很容易说，哦，我们从来没相信过那些。我的意思是，当然，国防部（DOD）在资助它，他们给人们服用LSD，把双胞胎放在不同的房间里，看他们是否能读懂对方的心思，让人们盯着农场动物看是否能通过心灵感应在精神上杀死它们。我的意思是，没人真正知道，你知道，谷歌一下，呃，他叫什么名字？约翰·C·莉莉（John C. Lilly）。谷歌一下，呃，莉莉的海豚实验。我的意思是，那全是国防部的钱。嗯，所以当人们意识到，天哪，给这只海豚喂LSD并不能让我真正与上帝交谈。那是一个
a bad idea. There's an insecurity that makes the world pivot pretty hard in the eighties when the money comes back on to something entirely else. And psychology is always these reactions and overreactions to itself, essentially, its core. And so when that happens, just like the Freudians, the pivot to cognitive therapy, behavioral therapy was too hard, too harsh. And now you're seeing a pivot back, you know, really as the millennials come of age and age into the profession and the boomers kids are saying no, you know, to that, um, you know, and this, that, that retreat, I think into the unconscious in the seventies, um, that fascination with these altered states and people like Carlos, uh,
糟糕的主意。在80年代，当资金转向完全不同的领域时，世界出现了一种不安全感，导致世界发生了剧烈的转变。心理学本质上总是对其自身进行反应和过度反应。所以当这种情况发生时，就像弗洛伊德学派一样，转向认知疗法、行为疗法太生硬、太严苛了。现在你看到了一个回转，你知道，随着千禧一代成年并进入这个行业，婴儿潮一代的孩子们说不，你知道，对那个，嗯，你知道，这种退缩，我认为退回到70年代的潜意识，嗯，对这些改变状态的迷恋，以及像卡洛斯·卡斯塔尼达（Carlos Castaneda）这样的人，嗯，
Castaneda and, um, you know, psychedelic journeys and even the word, you know, acid trip implies that you're taking your, it's taking you somewhere else. And that's somewhere it's real, you know, uh, all of those people, uh, sort of were paving the way for the destruction of their own perspective in a certain way. You know, there are people like Kurt Vonnegut, who I like, you know, Thomas Pynchon, who I like, Hunter S. Thompson, who I think is kind of limited. He's more of a stylist than like an intuitive thinker. But like, well, I mean he he had some that please don't have me come at me for that but you know they captured this kind of fragmenting and distort and disorienting nature of this post-modern self through looking at things like absurdity and paranoia and dark humor and people lying to themselves, and self-delusion, and all these chaotic images, you know, these
以及，你知道，迷幻之旅，甚至“酸性之旅”（acid trip）这个词，都暗示着你正在采取你的，它正在把你带到别的地方。而那个地方是真实的，你知道，呃，所有这些人，呃，在某种程度上为他们自己观点的毁灭铺平了道路。你知道，有像库尔特·冯内古特（Kurt Vonnegut）这样我喜欢的人，你知道，托马斯·品钦（Thomas Pynchon）我喜欢，亨特·S·汤普森（Hunter S. Thompson）我觉得有点局限。他更像是一个文体家，而不是一个直觉思想家。但是，嗯，我的意思是，他确实有一些，请不要因为这个来攻击我，但你知道，他们通过观察荒诞、偏执、黑色幽默、人们对自己撒谎、自我欺骗以及所有这些混乱的意象，捕捉到了这种后现代自我的碎片化、扭曲和令人迷失的本质，你知道，这些
reflected images of, like, uncertain times. I mean, and even in the one of the, that's one of the reasons why Thompson, even though I don't, like, love him the most as a writer, like, his stuff works, because he kind of just jumps into an experience, like, as a concert journalist, and, like, follows it around, and writes down all this weird stuff, and then at the end end is like i don't know what the point was maybe it was this you know which to me feels kind of dashed off but it is a reflection of kind of like you know how something works that appeals to people on different levels but there was this hallucinatory glimpse into this dark side of the american dream and like echoing disillusionment that all these people were starting to feel as kennedy nyes and nixon comes in, and then Nixon is revealed to be a crook. And then, you know, we're getting
反射出的意象，就像，不确定的时代。我的意思是，甚至在其中一个，这也是为什么汤普森，尽管我不是最喜欢他作为作家，但他的东西有效，因为他有点像是一个“贡佐记者”（concert journalist），直接跳进一种体验中，然后，跟着它走，写下所有这些奇怪的东西，然后在最后说，我不知道重点是什么，也许是这个，你知道，这对我来说感觉有点草率，但它反映了某种，你知道，某事如何运作，在不同层面上吸引人们，但这里有一种对美国梦阴暗面的幻觉式一瞥，以及所有这些人开始感受到的回响的幻灭感，当肯尼迪遇刺，尼克松上台，然后尼克松被揭露是一个骗子。然后，你知道，我们得到
rumors that the CIA is trying to overthrow countries and that it's assassinating, you know, leaders of the black civil rights movements. And all of these, all of these things, um, were happening at the same time that there's this digital age, there's this advent of personal computers, um, you know, in the homes and the workplaces and keep in mind they cost. Yeah. Yeah. There was a home computer, but it costs the amount that a helicopter costs. Like when they're just like, well, Bill Gates just dropped out of Harvard and fired up his computer. It's like, yeah, like that's like saying you're just like well bill gates just dropped out of harvard and fired up his computer it's like yeah like that's like saying you're gonna drop out of school and be self-made by firing up your lamborghini and you've got some um funding you know to fund your dropout so like well there's all this like promising i don't know if gates dropped out of harvard it was
传言说中央情报局试图推翻国家，并且正在暗杀，你知道，黑人民权运动的领导人。所有这些，所有这些事情，嗯，都发生在数字时代到来的同时，个人电脑的出现，嗯，你知道，在家庭和工作场所，记住它们的价格。是的。是的，有家用电脑，但它花费的钱相当于一架直升机。就像当他们说，比尔·盖茨刚从哈佛退学并启动了他的电脑。这就像，是的，这就像说你只是，好吧，比尔·盖茨刚从哈佛退学并启动了他的电脑，这就像，是的，这就像说你要退学并通过启动你的兰博基尼来白手起家，而且你有一些，嗯，资金，你知道，来资助你的退学。所以，嗯，有所有这些承诺，我不知道盖茨是否从哈佛退学，那是
some ivy like i can't remember uh but uh maybe it was berkeley i don't i need to look that up anyway there is this deluge of information that hits um this promise that there's going to be unprecedented access to all information that it's going to be connected that this technological revolution also you know it it it is exciting but it's also stressful you know to america's vision of a future and it's a time where we needed a vision of a future and so people get into fields like cybernetics and systems theory and you know trying to understand this relationship between humans and machines and what if a machine is just like a human that we haven't made smart enough to wake up and you know have sentience at or what if humans are just machines man um what if you could put them together what could you put a computer in a brain
某个常春藤盟校，我不记得了，呃，但呃，也许是伯克利，我需要查一下。总之，有一股信息洪流袭来，嗯，这种承诺，即人们将获得对所有信息的前所未有的访问权，它将被连接起来，这种技术革命也，你知道，它，它，它令人兴奋，但也令人压力重重，你知道，对美国对未来的愿景而言。这是一个我们需要未来愿景的时代，所以人们进入了控制论和系统论等领域，你知道，试图理解人类和机器之间的这种关系，如果机器就像一个我们还没有让它足够聪明到醒来并，你知道，拥有感知力的人类会怎样？或者如果人类只是机器呢，伙计，如果你能把它们放在一起会怎样？你能把电脑放进大脑里吗？
could you put a brain in a computer you know and but this shift towards the digital emphasized this retreat from a tangible real people moved into a realm of abstraction they're moving away from like i'm a farmer i grew a plant to like can i turn my computer into a plant basically or can i describe the nature of plants with a computer like the thing that is the dream becomes a representation of something real but no longer a thing that directly is real in a way that i think is inherently stressful um to society the individuals that make up the psychology and these lines between self and technology become blurred there, right? That's kind of what I'm saying. It's like, what is a machine and what isn't? That is a redefinition of self in a way that we don't always talk about
你能把大脑放进电脑里吗？你知道，但是这种向数字化的转变强调了从有形现实的退缩，人们进入了一个抽象的领域，他们正在远离像“我是一个农民，我种了一株植物”这样的想法，转向“我基本上能把我的电脑变成一株植物吗？”或者“我能用电脑描述植物的本质吗？”就像那个梦想变成了某种真实事物的表征，但不再是直接真实的事物，这在我看来本质上对社会、构成心理学的个体来说是令人压力的，自我和技术之间的界限在那里变得模糊了，对吧？这基本上就是我想说的。就像，什么是机器，什么不是？这是对自我的一种重新定义，我们并不总是谈论
as being separate from these movements. You know, these are all part of the same thing. And those countercultural movements in the 60s and the 70s, like they were striving for this individual liberation, this individual spiritual enlightenment. And that, I think, paved the way for their own inevitable co-option and destruction. Because they were prioritizing the subjective experience and embracing abstract realms of consciousness, but that left them vulnerable to the dominance of personal narratives. And this idea that there were going to be technological forces coming in and the myth of the individual and the self-made person. I mean, when you're kind of a hippie in the woods going off and trying to find God, you look incredibly unmarketable to the 80s that are coming.
它与这些运动是分开的。你知道，这些都是同一事物的一部分。60年代和70年代的那些反文化运动，就像他们正在为这种个人解放、这种个人精神启蒙而奋斗。而且我认为，这为他们自己不可避免的被收编和毁灭铺平了道路。因为他们优先考虑主观体验并拥抱抽象的意识领域，但这使他们容易受到个人叙事主导地位的影响。还有这种将会有技术力量介入的想法，以及个人和白手起家者的神话。我的意思是，当你是一个在树林里试图寻找上帝的嬉皮士时，你在即将到来的80年代看起来极其没有市场价值。
That is all about what I can create out here in the world and you're trying to create that in this inner world that i don't see and so when the culture pivots to a hyper objective lens of what are you what can you see touch taste how much money can you make none of that personal subjected inward wisdom and a lot of it wasn't really wisdom, but that's what they were trying to cultivate, was completely worthless all of a sudden. And you get a million interesting reactions to that, like the back-to-the-landers hippies and different things. But it really was such a fast turn in culture. You know, when oil got cheap again and our political preferences changed all of a sudden, and a lot more people had a, you know, opinion about the capital gains tax for some reason. And so like psychotherapy largely changes, you know, as these overreactions to itself,
那一切都关乎我能在这个世界上创造什么，而你却试图在那个我看不见的内心世界里创造它。所以当文化转向一种超客观的视角，即你是什么，你能看到、触摸、品尝什么，你能赚多少钱时，所有那些个人的、主观的、内在的智慧——其中很多并不是真正的智慧，但那是他们试图培养的东西——突然之间变得毫无价值。你得到了数百万种有趣的反应，比如回归土地的嬉皮士和各种不同的事情。但这确实是文化中如此快速的转变。你知道，当石油再次变得便宜，我们的政治偏好突然改变时，更多的人因为某种原因对资本利得税有了意见。所以心理治疗在很大程度上发生了变化，你知道，作为这些对其自身的过度反应，
which are overreactions to the nature of self is kind of what I'm getting at. You know, Freud split with that Jung and then Adler kind of thought both of them were immature and silly and trying to be visionary leaders. And then Reich, he gets kicked out of the psychoanalytic conference for, you know, wearing a knife and beating a stick on the ground and glaring at people, which would still probably get you kicked out of the psychoanalytic conference. And there's this emergence of a feminist and a multicultural approach to therapy too, that can kind of be seen as a response to the limitations of traditional psychoanalytic and humanistic models. Um, they, which those models were failing to account for the ways in the seventies and the sixties and seventies. Um,
也就是对自我本质的过度反应，这就是我想表达的。你知道，弗洛伊德与荣格分道扬镳，然后阿德勒觉得他们俩都不成熟、愚蠢，试图成为有远见的领导者。然后赖希（Reich），他因为，你知道，带着刀、在地上敲棍子并怒视别人而被踢出了精神分析会议，这在今天可能仍然会让你被踢出精神分析会议。而且还出现了女性主义和多元文化的治疗方法，这也可以被视为对传统精神分析和人文主义模型局限性的一种回应。嗯，它们，这些模型在70年代和60年代及70年代未能解释这些方式。嗯，
and some of this endured until the eighties and where things like gender or race or other forms of social identity were shaping our experiences, um, and opportunities in the world. So if I went into, you started to see, you know, like for example,
其中一些一直持续到80年代，当时性别、种族或其他形式的社会身份正在塑造我们的经历，嗯，以及在世界上的机会。所以如果我进入，你开始看到，你知道，例如，
a lot of second wave feminists became young and you know they're they're older but a lot of those guys are still working and um a lot of people said well psychoanalysis is inherently racist i'm gonna do this new type of thing but there was this reaction to the world has changed. And so the self and the individual identity of the person is different because the world has changed. And so your model talking about this old conception of self that is trying to encompass everybody, I don't fit into that anymore. And we need a new model of therapy. So you get this sort of like individualization and more specialization of things. That, you know, academia, the medical profession, they like that. They like specificity. They like specialization. You know, like we want
许多第二波女性主义者成为了荣格学派，你知道，她们年纪大了，但那些人中很多还在工作，而且，嗯，很多人说，好吧，精神分析本质上是种族主义的，我要做这种新的东西。但这是对世界已经改变的一种反应。所以人的自我和个人身份是不同的，因为世界已经改变了。所以你的模型谈论这种试图涵盖所有人的旧自我概念，我不再适合那个了。我们需要一种新的治疗模型。所以你得到了这种类似于个体化和事物更加专业化的东西。这，你知道，学术界、医疗行业，他们喜欢那样。他们喜欢具体性。他们喜欢专业化。你知道，就像我们想要
there to be 150 credentials, not just, oh, I'm a therapist. I'm doing therapy. What kind of therapy are you doing? Yeah, you know, a little of this, a little of that. No, you have to be doing DBT therapy with a focus on complex, um, PTSD or complex trauma informed quality care to certificate, whatever you get that out of that idea, you know, in the, in the same way that they were radicals and leftists kind of did that in the 60s and the 70s to therapy but when they did it i don't think they saw that it was um something that was taking it was going to be taken away from them and used against them essentially um that need for this kind of academic insecurity of like high specialization of everything was another thing that in the 80s the left was kind of paving its way for its own destruction in the field
有150种证书，而不是仅仅说，哦，我是一名治疗师。我正在做治疗。你在做什么样的治疗？是的，你知道，一点这个，一点那个。不，你必须在做DBT（辩证行为疗法），专注于复杂的，嗯，PTSD（创伤后应激障碍）或复杂的创伤知情优质护理，无论你从那个想法中得到什么证书，你知道，以同样的方式，他们在60年代和70年代对治疗做了那种激进和左翼的事情，但当他们这样做时，我不认为他们看到它是，嗯，某种正在被拿走并基本上被用来对付他们的东西。那种对一切高度专业化的学术不安全感，是80年代左派为自己的毁灭铺平道路的另一件事，在这一领域
or to have any sort of say in where the field was going um and you know these uh you know liberation psychology and some things like that in the 80s and the 90s are also i mean i think you can see those as reactions to, well, you know, I'm indicating that I'm a safe kind of therapy for a certain kind of person that feels alienated by a different, the mainstream type of therapy. But largely those things never were very influential in the 80s and 90s to my memory. And you don't find them now. You know, I don't know that I could go out and find like a liberation therapist in Birmingham today in anywhere in Alabama. Um, I've never come across one, but my point here is that therapy is not driven by these abstract theoretical concerns. Really.
或者对该领域的发展方向有任何发言权。而且你知道，这些，嗯，你知道，解放心理学和80年代和90年代的一些类似的东西，我的意思是，我认为你可以把它们看作是对以下情况的反应：好吧，你知道，我正在表明我是一种对某种感到被主流治疗类型疏远的人来说是安全的治疗。但在很大程度上，据我记忆，这些东西在80年代和90年代从未产生过很大影响。而且你现在也找不到它们了。你知道，我不知道我今天是否能在伯明翰或阿拉巴马州的任何地方找到一位解放治疗师。嗯，我从来没遇到过，但我的观点是，治疗并不是由这些抽象的理论关注所驱动的。真的不是。
It's driven by like concrete needs and demands of individuals and communities seeking to make sense of their own experience and challenge oppressive and limiting narratives that shape their lives. And that happens as the world changes, and then people bring that into therapy, and then the therapy models start to break up because the therapist doesn't feel it represents their people, or they're not making money, and the modality dies out. And so that process is messy, just like talking about the self of a person or the history and soul of a country. But I think it's interesting. And I also think it's something that
它是由寻求理解自身经历并挑战塑造其生活的压迫性和限制性叙事的个人和社区的具体需求和要求所驱动的。当世界发生变化时，这种情况就会发生，然后人们将其带入治疗中，然后治疗模型开始瓦解，因为治疗师觉得它不能代表他们的人民，或者他们赚不到钱，这种模式就消亡了。所以这个过程是混乱的，就像谈论一个人的自我或一个国家的历史和灵魂一样。但我认为这很有趣。而且我也认为这是我们需要
we need to reflect on. And the limitations of any model of therapy, right? They're going to be essentially limitations in its theory of self, because that theory, you know, of psychotherapy has to presuppose the way that the therapist understands and solves the problem. And if that process, you know, problem detection and problem conception, and then solution to the problem, feedback loop is broken, then you get stuck and you can't move out of it because the person is, you know, detecting the problem wrong or hearing the problem wrong or treating the problem wrong. And then going back to the same solution. And I'll give a couple examples of what I mean, because that's a messy idea, but I'll just give two, like I'm running really long, but like
反思的事情。以及任何治疗模型的局限性，对吧？它们本质上将是其自我理论的局限性，因为那个心理治疗理论，你知道，必须预设治疗师理解和解决问题的方式。如果那个过程，你知道，问题检测和问题构思，然后是问题解决方案，反馈循环被打破了，那么你就会被困住，无法走出来，因为那个人，你知道，检测问题错误，或者听问题错误，或者治疗问题错误。然后回到同一个解决方案。我会举几个例子来说明我的意思，因为这是一个混乱的想法，但我只会举两个，就像我讲得太长了，但就像
when you do that, uh, those different models of therapy like so when i when i go through these examples like my point here is not that they're bad models my point is that any model of therapy when it is taken as absolute and the therapist can't see outside of the model anymore and you lose the force for the trees. Like that's when the model becomes bad. And so if you cling too rigidly to your model of therapy, you're going to end up traumatizing somebody because if they stick around and they keep coming back, you know, you're insisting that somebody, something about your model's conceptualization must cure them and work for them. And when they're not getting better, it's not working for them. And you're
当你这样做时，呃，那些不同的治疗模型，就像当我讲完这些例子时，我的观点不是说它们是糟糕的模型，我的观点是，任何治疗模型当它被视为绝对，而治疗师再也无法从模型之外看问题时，你就“只见树木，不见森林”。这就是模型变得糟糕的时候。所以如果你过于僵化地坚持你的治疗模型，你最终会给某人造成创伤，因为如果他们留下来并不断回来，你知道，你坚持认为你的模型概念化的某种东西一定能治愈他们并对他们有效。而当他们没有好转时，它对他们不起作用。而你
not integrative. You can't just pivot to another one, or you're not flexible. And you can't just be like, Hey man, I don't think this is working for you. You want me to try something else? You want to do whatever you get stuck in these feedback loops where the information that's going in is putting you back at the beginning and you can't get out of it. And a lot of that is based on a concept of self and how therapy is supposed to work. So here's an example, psychodynamic therapy, right? Um, a lot of psychodynamic therapy is about how this relationship between the parent and the child becomes the child's relationship to the world later. And in therapy, the therapist can detect and intuit that relationship by talking to the
不是整合性的。你不能只是转向另一个，或者你不灵活。你不能只是说，嘿伙计，我不认为这对你有用。你想让我尝试别的东西吗？你想做任何事，你都会陷入这些反馈循环中，进入的信息把你带回了起点，你无法摆脱它。而这很大程度上是基于一种自我概念以及治疗应该如何运作。所以这里有一个例子，心理动力学疗法，对吧？嗯，很多心理动力学疗法是关于父母和孩子之间的这种关系如何成为孩子后来与世界的关系。在治疗中，治疗师可以通过与
person and seeing how they relate to the therapist and then saying, oh, that must be how you related to the parent and you're projecting on me. And therefore you're projecting that same thing onto the world. And this is creating your problem. And I was going in and holding the projection of your parent I'm going to you know give you this reparative experience or insight and when you have that insight you will change your relationship to the parent that's internalized therefore change your relationship to the therapist and the world and then the world's your oyster or whatever that's sometimes
那个人交谈并观察他们如何与治疗师建立关系，然后说，哦，那一定是你与父母建立关系的方式，你正在向我投射。因此，你正在把同样的东西投射到世界上。这正在制造你的问题。而我正在进入并持有你父母的投射，我将，你知道，给你这种修复性的体验或洞察，当你有了那个洞察，你就会改变你与内化的父母的关系，从而改变你与治疗师和世界的关系，然后世界就是你的牡蛎，或者无论什么，这有时
true right like there's a lot, as a therapist or just as a person, I mean, whether or not you're able to see it, you're probably holding a bunch of projections of people's parents, but not everybody. There's a ton of therapists that I've seen that I projected because I've seen a lot of therapists. There's a couple of therapists that I've seen that I definitely projected a parental energy on and, you know, like reacted to them based on my own stuff. There's also ones who I didn't project anything on because that just wasn't how I saw them. I was kind of going to them for something different. They didn't have anything that activated that in me. But if you are psychoanalytic and everything is this projection of unresolved neuroses going back to childhood and I am the parent and you
是真的，对吧？就像有很多，作为一名治疗师或仅仅作为一个人，我的意思是，无论你是否能够看到它，你可能都持有许多人父母的投射，但不是所有人。我见过很多治疗师，我投射了，因为我见过很多治疗师。我见过几个治疗师，我确实把父母的能量投射到了他们身上，并且，你知道，就像基于我自己的东西对他们做出反应。也有一些我没有投射任何东西，因为那根本不是我看待他们的方式。我去找他们是为了别的东西。他们身上没有任何东西激活了我内心的那种东西。但如果你是精神分析学派的，一切都是回到童年的未解决神经症的投射，而我是父母，你
are projecting that on me and yet that isn't working because the patient's not doing that and you're inflexible and you don't have another tool then you just decide that you know that this person is projecting on you like a parent you keep trying to solve problems that way but that isn't what's happening, right? Like, I had a therapist a long time ago that was really, really bad, and he did some stuff that was not, I won't go into all that.
正在把那个投射到我身上，然而那并不奏效，因为病人并没有那样做，而你不灵活，你没有其他工具，那么你就决定，你知道，这个人正在像父母一样向你投射，你继续试图以那种方式解决问题，但那并不是正在发生的事情，对吧？就像，很久以前我有一个治疗师，他真的，真的很糟糕，他做了一些事情，不是，我不会深入谈论所有这些。
Like, there were things that he did that were just illegal, if not a board rule. They weren't like, you know, it wasn't sexual, it wasn't anything like that. he broke confidentiality just like not a competent guy older guy and he kept telling me um because he was super psychodynamic and he kept telling me all this stuff about how i like he would give me these ideas and i would just be like i mean a little bit i just i don't know man i was there and I don't think people think that about me It was a good guess, you know, like there's nothing wrong with forget. It's okay to be wrong. I considered your perspective
就像，他做了一些事情，如果不是违反委员会规则的话，简直就是违法的。它们不是，你知道，不是性的，不是那样的。他违反了保密原则，就像一个不称职的家伙，年纪较大，他一直告诉我，嗯，因为他超级心理动力学，他一直告诉我所有这些关于我如何，就像他会给我这些想法，而我只会像，我的意思是，有一点点，我只是，我不知道伙计，我在那里，我不认为人们那样看我。这是一个很好的猜测，你知道，就像忘记也没什么错。错了也没关系。我考虑了你的观点
I just don't see it and then it was I was in a power struggle with him Because he was the parent and I was the child and I wasn't accepting him and he needed I was gonna be in a fight for the world until I learned how to grow up and not be angry with daddy. And I was like, I just don't really see you that way. I just think you're not right, um, on this issue. And so I took his perspective that he was telling me these people had these thoughts about me or whatever, and my wife and my friends, and they were like, no, um, don't talk to that guy. That's not right. You know, he's not making room for you in therapy, but I wasn't a therapist yet. I had been through graduate school, but I was really insecure about
我只是没看出来，然后就是我与他陷入了权力斗争，因为他是父母，我是孩子，而我不接受他，他需要，我将陷入一场为世界而战的斗争，直到我学会如何长大，不再对爸爸生气。而我当时想，我真的不那样看你。我只是认为你不对，嗯，在这个问题上。所以我采纳了他的观点，他告诉我这些人对我有这些想法，或者其他什么，我的妻子和朋友，他们说，不，嗯，不要和那个家伙说话。那是不对的。你知道，他在治疗中没有为你留出空间，但我当时还不是治疗师。我读完了研究生，但我对
whether or not I could do it. So I stayed around a lot longer than I should. It was like, maybe he's doing psychodrama. Maybe he's lying to me because what he's saying is getting like more and more weird. Then finally I found out like a bunch of, uh, I found out that there were other people who were seeing him that I knew. Um, also like if you're going to see multiple people from somebody's family and then not tell them about it and then use information from those sessions, that's not ethical. Don't do that. He was doing that. Um, but anyway, like, so this will tell you like, uh, I'm, I'm telling on myself, like being a bad patient. But so like, I ask one of the people, I was like, Hey, when you ask about this idea, what does he say?
我是否能做到这一点感到非常不安全。所以我待的时间比我应该待的时间长得多。就像，也许他在做心理剧。也许他在对我撒谎，因为他所说的话变得越来越奇怪。最后我发现，嗯，有一群，呃，我发现还有其他人也在看他，我认识他们。嗯，还有，如果你要看某人家庭中的多个人，然后不告诉他们，然后使用那些会话中的信息，那是不道德的。不要那样做。他当时就在那样做。嗯，但总之，就像，所以这会告诉你，就像，呃，我，我正在告发自己，就像一个糟糕的病人。但所以就像，我问其中一个人，我当时想，嘿，当你问这个想法时，他怎么说？
Cause whatever I say, which I think is kind of thoughtful and nice. Like, it's not like he's like, Oh, I just don't agree with you or something. He just says, that's wrong. That's absolutely wrong. You can't believe that. And I'm like, well, you know, whatever. Um, I, I just disagree with you. Like one of the things he would always tell me is like, nobody can be a therapist until they're 40 years old. And I was like, well, I'd kind of like to be a therapist for the next five years, and I don't know that that's true because there's a lot of therapists. No, no, no, no one can be a therapist until they're 40 years old
因为无论我说什么，我认为这都是一种体贴和友好的想法。就像，他并不是说，哦，我只是不同意你或什么的。他只是说，那是错的。那是绝对错误的。你不能相信那个。而我当时想，好吧，你知道，无论什么。嗯，我，我只是不同意你。就像他总是告诉我的事情之一是，没有人能在40岁之前成为治疗师。而我当时想，好吧，我有点想在接下来的五年里成为治疗师，而且我不知道那是真的，因为有很多治疗师。不，不，不，没有人能在40岁之前成为治疗师
because there won't be enough seasoning on the pot. And I was like, well, I know a lot of therapists that aren't 40, Bill. I don't know what you mean. Oh, you might know therapists that aren't 40, but nobody can be a therapist. Just whatever, weird stuff like that. So I was like, okay, tell me something that he told you about, what particular issue, not relevant to that person, but just in general about the nature of therapy.
因为锅里没有足够的调料。而我当时想，好吧，我知道很多不到40岁的治疗师，比尔。我不知道你是什么意思。哦，你可能认识不到40岁的治疗师，但没有人能成为治疗师。只是无论什么，像那样奇怪的事情。所以我当时想，好吧，告诉我一些他告诉你的关于，什么具体问题，与那个人无关，只是关于治疗本质的一般性问题。
And so I went into therapy, and i just told him that exact same thing like i was like hey here's the thing that i think which i didn't think but it was what he had just told somebody who i knew that was also seeing it the day before and he exploded he's like that's the worst thing ever why would you why do you think you can come in here and say inflammatory things to me? And I was like, I didn't. I was just pretending to have a thought that I didn't actually have. But, you know, whatever. And that was when I realized, like, oh, it doesn't matter what I say.
所以我去接受治疗，我只是告诉他完全相同的事情，就像我当时想，嘿，这是我想到的事情，我并没有想到，但这是他前一天刚告诉另一个我也认识的正在看他的人的事情，他爆炸了，他说那是史上最糟糕的事情，为什么你会，你为什么认为你可以走进这里并对我说煽动性的话？而我当时想，我没有。我只是假装有一个我实际上没有的想法。但是，你知道，无论什么。那就是我意识到的时候，就像，哦，我说什么并不重要。
Like, the point of this is that you want me to say, I'm sorry, daddy, I'm wrong. And that not for me, but for you, this is a weird relationship where every time I have insight or I'm right, I'm failing to live into this paternal dynamic that you think underlies reality of guy comes in, he's a little boy. If he doesn't get a scent to me, whatever. It was very weird. You, you see things like that where the person's like, Oh, well you see feedback loops like this, right? You know, cognitive behavioral therapy, where do you get feedback loops there? Well, you know, like CBT is interesting and it's good, um, for, for some things, but those things are largely intellectual. And even when you're getting into emotion, like you're still getting into talking about emotion or handling emotion with thought.
就像，这点的意义在于你想要我说，对不起爸爸，我错了。而且那不是为了我，而是为了你，这是一种奇怪的关系，每次我有洞察力或我是对的，我都没有活出你认为构成现实的这种父权动态，即一个男人走进来，他是一个小男孩。如果他不赞同我，无论什么。这非常奇怪。你，你看到像那样的事情，那个人就像，哦，好吧，你看到像这样的反馈循环，对吧？你知道，认知行为疗法（CBT），你在哪里得到反馈循环？嗯，你知道，就像CBT很有趣，而且它很好，嗯，对于，对于某些事情，但那些事情在很大程度上是智力上的。即使当你进入情感时，就像你仍然在谈论情感，或者用思想处理情感。
So it's a pretty top level kind of therapy. It's pretty psychoeducational. Some people need it. But what you get is, you know, the scope of what like is, and CBT is not terribly deep. I've never read where Beck says this is where my theory of emotion comes from, but I think it was just things that were around then. There's definitely RABT in it. He knew Alice.
所以这是一种相当顶层的治疗。它相当具有心理教育意义。有些人需要它。但你得到的是，你知道，像是什么的范围，而且CBT并不太深。我从来没读过贝克（Beck）说这是我的情感理论来源，但我认为这只是当时周围的东西。里面肯定有RABT（理性情绪行为疗法）。他认识埃利斯（Ellis）。
There's probably some two-factor theory of emotion stuff. There's cognitive appraisal theory. None of these theories of emotion, most of them have kind of been replaced, and they're not terribly interesting. And so as a result, I think cognitive behavioral therapy is not great at doing things like processing flashback re-experiencing of PTSD. I think it's good at teaching you how to white knuckle through things and make you endure distress tolerance. But if I can take distress away, there's stress tolerance is a great skill to have, but if you can take distress away,
可能有一些情感的双因素理论的东西。有认知评价理论。这些情感理论中没有一个，大多数都已经以某种方式被取代了，而且它们并不太有趣。因此，我认为认知行为疗法在处理诸如PTSD的闪回重现之类的事情上并不擅长。我认为它擅长教你如何咬牙切齿地度过难关，让你忍受痛苦耐受力。但如果我能消除痛苦，痛苦耐受力是一项很好的技能，但如果你能消除痛苦，
you don't need it. So when somebody is coming in, you know, in CBT and they're saying like that, um, they're saying that like they're having this bad thing and it's not affecting their behavior a lot of the cbt therapists and there's cbt therapists who are great but they're not following cbt as it's written or as beck thought um they're saying i'm doing cbt and they're using what you should do in therapy which is you learn your model or you learn a couple models and then you apply them until they become your own and you have realizations and discoveries and you take things in a new direction. So like with something like CBT, if the thing is not affecting behavior, the therapist tends to
你就不需要它了。所以当有人进来时，你知道，在CBT中，他们说，嗯，他们说他们有这种糟糕的事情，而且它对他们的行为影响不大，许多CBT治疗师，而且有很棒的CBT治疗师，但他们并没有按照书面或贝克所想的那样遵循CBT，他们说我正在做CBT，他们正在使用你在治疗中应该做的事情，也就是你学习你的模型，或者你学习几个模型，然后你应用它们，直到它们成为你自己的，你有了发现和发现，你把事情带向一个新的方向。所以就像CBT这样的东西，如果事情不影响行为，治疗师倾向于
act like it isn't relevant because it's not measurable. Even if it's not detect, even when it's affecting emotion, if you're not saying, well, I feel one out of 10 sad, and I feel two out of, you know, 10 afraid, you know, that emotion may be consciously there. You still may be avoiding huge parts of your life and you need somebody to help pull you back into a series of self, but I think if you apply CBT in a thick paste, in a vacuum, it misses. It misses the depth and complexity of self. And so the person sometimes is asking for things that the therapist doesn't pick up on. So those are kind of the feedback loops that I mean, just two examples of how that can work.
表现得好像它不相关，因为它不可测量。即使它没有检测到，即使当它影响情感时，如果你不说，嗯，我感到十分之一的悲伤，我感到十分之二的恐惧，你知道，那种情感可能在意识上存在。你可能仍然在回避你生活中巨大的部分，你需要有人帮助把你拉回一系列自我中，但我认为如果你在真空中以厚糊状应用CBT，它就错过了。它错过了自我的深度和复杂性。所以那个人有时在要求治疗师没有察觉到的东西。所以这些就是我所说的反馈循环，只是两个例子，说明它是如何运作的。
Because like no model of psychotherapy can 100% contain the self, especially ones that have a limited definition of it. No relationship between two people is 100% psychodynamic attachment projections. It's just not. There's more going on. And no, like, you know, just, you know, cognitive and then behaviors based on that cognition leading to a belief that is completely conscious and I stated and know it. Neither can that contain the series of self and the way that CBT, I think, tries to make it. And one of the reasons why I think CBT and ABA are kind of nefarious and a lot of cognitive therapies or any of those things that came in the nineties that had like solution focused or brief treatment or time limited, just strapped onto the top of it, you know, time limited psychodynamic, uh, you know, whatever, what the reason I think they were kind of nefarious is that they either knew or they were selected by a system that knew that we wanted therapy to be shorter
因为就像没有心理治疗模型能100%包含自我，特别是那些定义有限的模型。两个人之间的关系不是100%的心理动力学依恋投射。根本不是。还有更多的事情在发生。而且没有，就像，你知道，只是，你知道，认知，然后基于那种认知的行为导致了一种完全有意识且我陈述并知道的信念。两者都不能包含自我系列，以及我认为CBT试图使其成为的那种方式。而且我认为CBT和ABA（应用行为分析）之所以有点邪恶，以及90年代出现的许多认知疗法或任何那些带有解决方案聚焦或简短治疗或限时治疗的东西，只是绑在它上面，你知道，限时心理动力学，呃，你知道，无论什么，我认为它们有点邪恶的原因是，它们要么知道，要么被一个知道我们想要治疗更短的系统所选择
and cheaper at the expense of therapy being good. And that wasn't just therapy. I mean, look at the eighties. Would you rather drive a Cadillac from the fifties or would you rather drive a Cadillac from the seventies? Would you rather anything that GM made? I mean, have you ever seen a GM product from the 70s on the road? We made everything cheaper at the expense of it being good. We charged a lot of money to it. Maybe you paid the same amount, but it was cheaper for GM to make, which is why they made a whole lot more money. Well, they didn't really make a lot of money in the 70s because stuff got terrible, but you know what I mean. When you make something for less money and you sell it for the same price, you make more money. And the 80s was really into that kind of thinking, short-term thinking.
且更便宜，以牺牲治疗质量为代价。那不仅仅是治疗。我的意思是，看看80年代。你宁愿开50年代的凯迪拉克，还是宁愿开70年代的凯迪拉克？你宁愿要通用汽车（GM）制造的任何东西吗？我的意思是，你见过70年代的通用汽车产品在路上吗？我们让一切都变得更便宜，以牺牲其质量为代价。我们为此收取了很多钱。也许你付了同样的钱，但对通用汽车来说制造它更便宜，这就是为什么他们赚了更多的钱。好吧，他们在70年代并没有真正赚很多钱，因为东西变得很糟糕，但你知道我的意思。当你以更少的钱制造某样东西，并以同样的价格出售它时，你就赚了更多的钱。而80年代确实沉迷于那种思维，短期思维。
And so the world around the self is something that we haven't talked about a ton in 2 and 3. And I want to talk about it in part 4 of this series which is why we kind of go through the world changing around therapy so that it doesn't sound like therapy just changes around the world you know these things are connected in a way that is interesting to me and a lot of Jungian thinking explains that stuff and a language that I like, but I'm always looking for other languages that describe things well, because I think the more, um, that you know, uh, the more ways you know how to say something. And I don't mean languages like German and English. I mean,
所以自我周围的世界是我们没有在2和3中谈论太多的东西。我想在这一系列的第4部分中谈论它，这就是为什么我们有点经历世界围绕治疗的变化，这样听起来就不像是治疗只是围绕世界变化，你知道，这些事情以一种对我来说有趣的方式连接在一起，很多荣格思想解释了那些东西，以及我喜欢的一种语言，但我总是在寻找描述事物很好的其他语言，因为我认为越多，嗯，你知道，呃，你知道怎么说某件事的方法越多。我指的不是德语和英语这样的语言。我的意思是，
languages like Jungian thought, Freudian thought, Nietzsche existentialism like phenomenology these things that are a language that's philosophical that kind of becomes a lens to let you see something and the more ways that you can say the same thing the more the people keep that can kind of hear you can see it better but also the more ways that like you can see it clearer because you're looking maybe at the same gem, but through different faucets of that same gem, you know, different angles of the same thing. Um, so there's a guy, um, German philosopher, um, Peter Sloterdijk, uh, or Deke, maybe, I don't know. It's, I think it's a Dutch name on a German guy, but, um but he's like a cultural theorist that has this idea of spheres that I think is really relevant and
像荣格思想、弗洛伊德思想、尼采存在主义、像现象学这样的语言，这些东西是一种哲学语言，它变成了一种让你看到某物的镜头，而你能说出同一件事的方法越多，人们能听到你的方法就越多，他们就能看得越清楚，而且你也能看得越清楚，因为你可能是在看同一颗宝石，但通过那颗宝石的不同切面，你知道，同一事物的不同角度。嗯，所以有一个人，嗯，德国哲学家，嗯，彼得·斯洛特戴克（Peter Sloterdijk），呃，或者Deke，也许，我不知道。它是，我认为这是一个荷兰名字的德国人，但，嗯，但他是一位文化理论家，他有这种球体（spheres）的想法，我认为这非常相关且
kind of interesting. And again, I'm trying to do more philosophy on this one, but I'm not a philosophy guy. I'm dilettante and I can't teach a class on these people. So it's not like I'm an expert. I'm not trying to be, I'm trying to relate these things back to psychotherapy and psychotherapy to these things But his concept of spheres is relational and it's also kind of topological It's this way to understand human existence as sort of psychic territories That just like that nature of self from the beginning wax Wayne eclipse and self from the beginning wax, wane, eclipse. And these spheres can be thought of as like networks of relationships that carry in a, they carry in human beings. And so with individuals, they sort of emerge as nodes within these dense interconnected networks. This is a very like post-digital type of philosophy, which is maybe why it's interesting to
有点有趣。而且再一次，我试图在这个问题上做更多的哲学探讨，但我不是一个哲学人。我是业余爱好者，我不能教关于这些人的课。所以这不像我是专家。我不是想成为专家，我试图把这些东西联系回心理治疗，把心理治疗联系回这些东西。但他的球体概念是关系的，它也有一点拓扑学意义。这是一种理解人类存在的方式，作为某种心理领土，就像从一开始就盈亏、蚀相的自我本质，从一开始就盈亏、蚀相。这些球体可以被认为是像关系网络，它们承载着，它们承载着人类。所以对于个体来说，他们作为这些密集互联网络中的节点出现。这是一种非常后数字类型的哲学，这也许就是为什么它对我来说很有趣。
me. Like there's a lot of, it would be very hard for someone to have this kind of vision without knowing, even if it is tangentially about computers through the world, you know. And these spheres, they have no clear boundaries, but they have some relations that extend further than others, and they create this complex and open-ended web of connection. And the metaphor of a network is useful, but he's hesitant to use network, he said, because it implies that the human being is at the center, and he doesn't see that. The sphere just is the center, and it has human beings in it and so you know instead he suggests that all the spheres are they're like um they just extend in all in a direction but without a clear core without a clear center they're sort of like uh ripples maybe is a better term like ripples of influence and in in slaughter deke's view like humans don't exist as individuals, but they're always a part of intimate spheres. And so you're getting rid of the idea of the individual and looking at
就像，一个人很难在不知道，即使是关于计算机通过世界，你知道，的情况下有这种愿景。而且这些球体，它们没有明确的边界，但它们有一些关系比其他关系延伸得更远，它们创造了这个复杂且开放的连接网。网络这个隐喻很有用，但他对使用网络犹豫不决，他说，因为它暗示人类处于中心，而他并没有看到这一点。球体本身就是中心，它里面有人类，所以你知道，相反，他建议所有的球体都是，它们就像，嗯，它们只是向各个方向延伸，但没有明确的核心，没有明确的中心，它们有点像，呃，涟漪，也许是一个更好的术语，就像影响的涟漪。在斯洛特戴克的观点中，人类并不作为个体存在，但他们总是亲密球体的一部分。所以你正在摆脱个体的概念，并观察
specific ideology and cultural movements, but not in a historical way. In a way, that those things are people who are insulating themselves from reality with a certain kind of belief. Like they're protecting themselves and understanding something by believing these things together. And no one person believing something makes it a sphere. You need a whole lot of people sheltering under these umbrellas of belief in order to be able to make one. And so, you know, in his theory, there's humans first, they all coexist within this shared sphere. And then later they reemerge as differentiated people. And this challenges, you know, a lot of philosophical language about a self-contained subject. And
特定的意识形态和文化运动，但不是以历史的方式。在某种程度上，这些人通过某种特定的信仰将自己与现实隔绝开来。就像他们通过共同相信这些东西来保护自己并理解某些事物。并不是某一个人相信什么就能形成一个领域。你需要一大群人躲在这些信仰的保护伞下才能形成一个领域。所以，你知道，在他的理论中，首先是人类，他们都共存于这个共享的领域中。然后，他们后来又作为分化的人重新出现。这挑战了许多关于自足主体的哲学语言。而且
like, while he's making a cosmology, he's not super interested in being specific about it. It's sort of heaps of metaphors and relational gesticulating. So you can't say like, like you could with some philosophers with specificity exactly what they're saying. He says Nietzsche is kind of his guy, but in the way that he sort of just throws on a concept and doesn't care what it blows up.
就像他在构建宇宙论时，他并不太热衷于具体化。这更像是堆砌隐喻和关系姿态。所以你不能像对待某些哲学家那样，确切地说出他们在说什么。他说尼采算是他的同道中人，但他那种随手抛出一个概念，却不在乎它会引发什么后果的方式，确实很像。
And then also doesn't bother to like explain what it means and how allegorical. I mean, I think he's more similar to Plato than maybe he would say, um, because we still don't know how to read Plato, um, any better than the people listening to him being like,
而且他也不费心去解释这意味着什么，以及它是多么具有寓意。我的意思是，我觉得他可能比他自己承认的更像柏拉图，嗯，因为我们仍然不知道如何解读柏拉图，嗯，并不比那些听他说话的人更好，他们会问，
what do you mean? You know, are you saying that there's actually like a spiritual place where the idea of form gives the chair its chairness or is this just like an idea about whatever and you know there's still a lot of debate about what plato meant um but the this idea of like the individual you know is not really an individual. They're always, like, occupying multiple positions and multiple spheres. And that there's this multiplicity of perspective is interesting. And so there's this notion of having this fixed identity and secure place in the world. And for Slenderdeak, like, that is this illusion of this philosophy
你是什么意思？你是说真的有一个精神场所，理念的形式赋予了椅子“椅子性”，还是这仅仅是一个关于什么的观点？你知道，关于柏拉图的本意仍然有很多争论。嗯，但是这种关于个人的想法，你知道，并不是真正的个人。他们总是占据着多个位置和多个领域。这种视角的多元性很有趣。所以，存在着一种拥有固定身份和世界中安全位置的概念。对于斯洛特戴克来说，这就是意识哲学的幻觉。
of consciousness. Instead, being in a sphere is this ongoing act of creation where human beings must actively construct a home for themselves. But it's not a home in the wilderness. It's a home in the cosmos of figuring out what the self is and what the world around them is and what that means. And then that is done in different spheres of life. Who I am as a Christian, who I am as an American, who I am as a person, who I am as a material being, a subjective being. The natures of those things change wildly, you know, over time. And there's some people, philosophers usually,
相反，身处一个领域是一个持续的创造行为，人类必须积极地为自己构建一个家。但这并不是荒野中的家。而是在宇宙中弄清楚自我是什么，周围的世界是什么，以及这意味着什么。这是在生活的不同领域中完成的。我作为基督徒是谁，我作为美国人是谁，我作为一个人是谁，我作为物质存在、主体存在是谁。这些事物的本质随着时间的推移发生了巨大的变化。而且有些哲学家通常，
who come in and they have an idea that's like so influential, right? That you have to like engage with them whether or not you know who they are for the rest of time. Like, you know, Plato, when Neoplatonism happens, you can't have Christianity anymore and ignore it. You have to have some way of answering these questions that Plato brings up or addressing them. Like, you know, Gnosticism is this attempt to deal with a lot of those things. You know, all religion is sort of in that conversation because before then the Greeks were just being like, I don't know, like there's like maybe there's stuff and things that makes it alive.
他们提出一个非常有影响力的观点，对吧？以至于无论你是否知道他们是谁，你都必须在余生中与他们打交道。就像，你知道，柏拉图，当新柏拉图主义出现时，你不能再拥有基督教却忽视它。你必须以某种方式回答柏拉图提出的这些问题或解决它们。就像，你知道，诺斯替教就是试图处理其中许多事情。你知道，所有的宗教都在某种程度上参与了那场对话，因为在那之前，希腊人只是说，我不知道，就像也许有一些东西让它变得有生命。
Like there's like a juice that you could pull out of it that makes me alive if you pulled the juice out of me, but the rock doesn't have the juice. So it's not alive. Or maybe like there's different kinds of life. There's like the ability to be alive and die, but there's also the ability to move, which is a different kind of life. And then there's also like the ability to like think and reason, which is a kind of life only men have. And there's just three types of it. And then Plato kind of comes in and says, there's a spiritual immaterial world. And then there's also a material objective world. And
就像有一种汁液，如果你把它从我身上抽出来，我就能活着，但石头没有这种汁液。所以它没有生命。或者也许有不同种类的生命。有那种能活着并死亡的能力，但也有移动的能力，这是另一种生命。还有那种思考和推理的能力，这是只有人类才有的生命。它只有三种类型。然后柏拉图走过来说，有一个精神上的非物质世界。还有一个物质的客观世界。而且
maybe they're somehow in communication with each other or one is good and one is bad and we should reject the other, whatever. But everyone has to like wrestle with this idea of like, oh yeah, we do have an internal conception and then live in this outer world that doesn't really care forever. You know, and you get like mid neoplatonism and it moves further away from anything he would have thought, but it's people struggling with like the, the, the problems that he creates. And those things sort of create these spheres, right? Like you can't go back and, and forget, even if you can't, even if you don't have the intellectual knowledge or historical knowledge to trace that development back to plato you're still in a different sphere
也许它们在某种程度上相互交流，或者一个是好的，一个是坏的，我们应该拒绝另一个，等等。但每个人都必须与这种想法搏斗，即，哦，是的，我们确实有一个内在的概念，然后生活在这个并不真正关心的外部世界中。你知道，你会得到像中期新柏拉图主义这样的东西，它离他原本想的任何东西都越来越远，但这是人们在挣扎于他所创造的问题。而这些东西在某种程度上创造了这些领域，对吧？就像你不能回去，也不能忘记，即使你没有智力知识或历史知识来追溯那个发展到柏拉图，你仍然处于一个不同的领域，
that has broken the old one and it can never go back to where it used to be and and he says you know slaughter deke says that we do this for protective immunization. Not as individual subjects, but, you know, co-subjects. Like, we have to share norms and values and symbolic practices, and we have to do that to insulate the world from these external irritants that come in, like a question Plato asked, maybe, right? You can't start a religion and not engage with the difference between the material and the spiritual or the objective and the subjective. You can't really create a big movement without doing that anymore. Humanity sort of can't forget what it knows, even if it doesn't remember why it And so these external irritants are anxiety creating. And he sees the spheres as this kind of greenhouse that we build.
它打破了旧的领域，再也回不到过去的样子了。他说，你知道，斯洛特戴克说我们这样做是为了保护性免疫。不是作为个体主体，而是作为共同主体。就像，我们必须分享规范、价值观和象征性实践，我们必须这样做来保护世界免受这些外部刺激的影响，比如柏拉图可能提出的问题，对吧？你不能开启一个宗教而不去处理物质与精神、客观与主观之间的差异。你不能再在不这样做的情况下创造一个大运动了。人类在某种程度上无法忘记它所知道的，即使它不记得为什么。所以这些外部刺激会产生焦虑。他把这些领域看作是我们建造的一种温室。
He says, I think, air conditioning at one point. But it's not just this matter of like complexity reduction and and trying to like have an easier life the spheres are like also characterized by this kind of complex interplay of multiple perspectives and possibilities which allows for a flexible and creative response to different kinds of situations to new. So it's a mode of being, um, which I think is why he says that he is basically writing where Heidegger started to get it wrong because Heidegger is into, you know, Dasein, right? You know, being, uh, how to, how to let being be, or you rest being into being. And I think that's what he means here is the
我想他有一次提到了空调。但这不仅仅是简化复杂性并试图让生活更轻松的问题，这些领域还具有多种视角和可能性的复杂相互作用的特征，这允许对不同类型的情况做出灵活和创造性的反应。所以这是一种存在模式，嗯，我想这就是为什么他说他基本上是在写海德格尔开始出错的地方，因为海德格尔沉迷于，你知道，此在（Dasein），对吧？你知道，存在，嗯，如何让存在成为存在，或者你将存在带入存在。我想这就是他在这里的意思，
spheres aren't just about like, here's a clump of beliefs to reduce anxiety. It becomes a new mode of being human, of being self that has to be shared or else we don't feel like it's real. So it's this messy meshing of subject and object, subject and objectivity you know that it is my individual like unseen belief but also i have to have multiple people believing that same belief or else it's not a sphere um so you know there's this constant negotiation between the inside and the outside the self and the other and the familiar and the strange that is this ongoing process where we develop identities and positionalities and you know a lot of this again in the language of digital things the legend language of quantum physics right like molecular entanglement you know i think that he never says
领域不仅仅是关于，这里有一堆信仰来减少焦虑。它成为了一种新的人类存在模式，一种必须共享的自我存在模式，否则我们就觉得它不真实。所以这是主体和客体、主体和客观性的混乱交织，你知道，这是我个人的、未被看见的信仰，但我也必须有很多人相信同样的信仰，否则它就不是一个领域。嗯，所以你知道，在内部和外部、自我和他者、熟悉和陌生之间存在着不断的协商，这是一个持续的过程，我们在这个过程中发展身份和定位。你知道，很多这些再次用数字事物的语言，量子物理学的语言，对吧，比如分子纠缠，你知道，我想他从来没有
that uh in a way that i remember but but like that, not metaphor, but just reference point is there, sphere is there, right? We're in the age where somebody who has a degree in philosophy has encountered this stuff and is going to refer to those concepts as an image in their brain. And so, you know, the spherology offers this radically relational and decentered understanding of human existence, where it challenges all of these, you know, ideas of individual autonomy and territorial boundaries that we want to draw on a map and says, no, we're kind of there's, and I'm granted, I'm, I'm not an expert on this person, but from what I understand, you know, there's this first sphere, which are these bubbles, which is this maternal sphere.
以我记得的方式说出来，但是那种，不是隐喻，而是参考点在那里，领域在那里，对吧？我们处于这样一个时代，一个拥有哲学学位的人已经接触过这些东西，并将把这些概念作为大脑中的图像来引用。所以，你知道，球体学提供了一种激进的关系性和去中心化的人类存在理解，它挑战了所有这些，你知道，我们想要在地图上绘制的个人自主权和领土边界的想法，并说，不，我们是某种……而且我承认，我不是这个人的专家，但据我所知，你知道，有这个第一领域，也就是这些泡泡，这是母体领域。
And, or, and it represents this primordial and innate and symbiotic relationship between the mother and the child and the womb and it'seness and unity and it's not terribly complex. Then there's this metaphysical sphere of globes and that sphere emerges with the development of ancient civilizations and it's characterized by this belief in a cosmic order, divine creation, a sense of belonging to a larger whole. It includes this idea of a celestial sphere that encompasses the earth. Even before we knew the earth was a sphere, we talk about the dome, you know, or the firmament. You look up, what do you see with your eyes? You see a ball, right? And that was the world. That was the sphere sphere we were all kind of participating in it and people were roughly aligned into that is what that was our mode of being you know that was
而且，它代表了母亲和孩子、子宫之间原始的、先天的和共生的关系，它是整体性和统一性，并不太复杂。然后是球体的形而上学领域，那个领域随着古代文明的发展而出现，其特征是对宇宙秩序、神圣创造、归属于一个更大的整体的信念。它包括这个包含地球的天球的概念。甚至在我们知道地球是一个球体之前，我们就谈论穹顶，你知道，或者苍穹。你抬头看，你用眼睛看到了什么？你看到了一个球，对吧？那就是世界。那就是我们都在参与的球体领域，人们大致上与此保持一致，这就是我们的存在模式，你知道，那是
our potentiality and then there's this terrestrial sphere foam and that sphere is associated with this modern era and it's characterized by the fragmentation of the metaphysical sphere into multiple interconnected and overlapping spaces and it's a result of globalization and technological advancement and the proliferation of communication networks and and that you start to get this breaking up of that dome of the earth into these smaller things where people are believing diverse suffocation, diverse philosophies and ideologies. And, you know, there's, there's still a big dome, but we've,
我们的潜能。然后是这个陆地领域的泡沫，那个领域与现代相关联，其特征是形而上学领域碎片化为多个相互连接和重叠的空间，这是全球化和技术进步以及通信网络激增的结果。你开始看到地球的那个穹顶分裂成这些较小的东西，人们相信不同的哲学和意识形态。而且，你知道，仍然有一个大穹顶，但我们已经，
we've broken this communal understanding where we're sort of all under the shared space. And then the digital sphere you know the the continuing degradation of the foam you know by that point he says the digital age represents this existential i mean excuse me this extension of the like terrestrial sphere where virtual spaces and networks create new forms of interconnectedness and globalization. And these spheres, they are characterized by the increasing importance of information, data, digital, and there's a fragment, more of a fragmentation, where we become less and less able to share a language with very many people
我们已经打破了那种共享空间的共同理解。然后是数字领域，你知道，泡沫的持续退化，你知道，到那时他说数字时代代表了这种存在主义的，我是说，抱歉，这种陆地领域的延伸，虚拟空间和网络创造了新的互联和全球化形式。这些领域，它们的特征是信息、数据、数字的重要性日益增加，并且存在碎片化，更多的是碎片化，我们变得越来越无法与很多人共享一种语言，
at the same time right it's not like you're picking a sphere and then you hop to another one your life is separated into spheres of understanding different things different ways and in the beginning it's almost total overlap you know there is no Venn diagram and then we mean if there was one it was like this is my tribe this is yours or you know i'm dying and you're alive or you're alive whatever you know very simple things under this one cosmology and now like you know you have to believe things about politics about metaphysics about values about life about nationality even if you an American, you have to have different opinions on this war, um, different, uh, opinions about the same religion from within the same religion,
同时，对吧？这不像你选择了一个领域然后跳到另一个领域，你的生活被分离成理解不同事物的领域，不同的方式。在开始时，几乎是完全重叠的，你知道，没有维恩图，然后我们的意思是，如果有一个，它就像这是我的部落，这是你的，或者你知道，我快死了，你还活着，或者你还活着，无论如何，你知道，在这个宇宙论下非常简单的事情。而现在，就像，你知道，你必须相信关于政治、形而上学、价值观、生活、国籍的事情，即使你是一个美国人，你也必须对这场战争有不同的看法，嗯，对同一个宗教内部的同一个宗教有不同的看法，
from within the same sect of the same religion. And it's very unlikely that you line up with anyone at all in a way that is completely meaningful and overlapping and, um, all of yourself being present with all of theirs. It's harder to do, right? Or at least it's harder to do in these areas. Um, and, or it's harder to do all at once, if that makes sense. I remember there was this thing that I felt in high school that I was, like, journaling about badly, where I felt like there were people who understood parts of me, but I couldn't really be who all of I was around all of anybody. And I think that that feeling is very modern,
在同一个宗教的同一个教派内。而且你不太可能以一种完全有意义和重叠的方式与任何人保持一致，而且，嗯，你所有的自我都与他们所有的自我同时存在。这很难做到，对吧？或者至少在这些领域很难做到。嗯，或者同时做到这一点很难，如果这有意义的话。我记得我在高中时有这种感觉，我写日记写得很糟糕，我觉得有些人理解我的部分，但我不能在任何人面前真正成为完整的我。我认为这种感觉非常现代，
and that he's right there. And I mean, his personality is weird. Like he's a German, he's known for being very unconventional and provocative, you know, as a public persona. His work often blends these elements of like philosophy and psychology and anthropology and cultural criticism. And those make him very difficult to categorize within academic discipline because academia doesn't really like it when you're that integrative because it puts the whole notion of specialization which academia likes into well under a microscope it threatens the way that they want to operate because western academia especially like the language is based on celebrating the person who knows very much about one small area of knowledge.
而且他就在那里。我的意思是，他的个性很奇怪。就像他是一个德国人，以非常规和挑衅而闻名，你知道，作为一个公众人物。他的作品经常融合哲学、心理学、人类学和文化批评等元素。这些使他很难在学术学科中分类，因为学术界不太喜欢你那样整合，因为它把学术界喜欢的整个专业化概念置于显微镜下，它威胁到他们想要运作的方式，因为西方学术界，特别是语言，是基于赞美那个对一个小的知识领域了解非常多的人。
But if you have a broad knowledge, then academia will at first try and be like, oh, you're just a dilettante. You know a little bit about everything. But if you know a lot about a lot, then you just become a threat to the status quo of that. No, to know a lot means to know a lot about one thing, not a lot about many things. And he's just one of those people, you know, probably similar to Jung who kind of knew too much about too much, um, in a way where he started to make connections at very high levels about very high levels of knowledge that was very specialized. Um, and so I think that is probably why you get ripples of things like quantum mechanics and things like programming and things like cultural anthropology. You know, Jung in there, even though he doesn't always say that's what this is.
但如果你有广泛的知识，那么学术界起初会试图说，哦，你只是一个业余爱好者。你对每件事都了解一点。但如果你对很多事情了解很多，那么你就成了那种现状的威胁。不，了解很多意味着对一件事了解很多，而不是对很多事情了解很多。他就是那种人，你知道，可能类似于荣格，他对自己了解太多，嗯，以至于他开始在非常高的层面上建立关于非常专门化的知识的高层联系。嗯，所以我认为这可能就是为什么你会得到像量子力学、编程和文化人类学这样的涟漪。你知道，荣格在里面，即使他并不总是说这就是它。
He doesn't have to. And this is probably part of his point, right? Like, I think Slaughter Deke wants to deconstruct by, like, dismissing all of these disciplines in a humorous and sometimes flippant way like he's not terribly nice he's also not super self-serious and then um he also rather than like engaging directly with criticisms or clarifying his position he wants to just kind of like throw out this abstract philosophical um like like logic or something. He lodged this ideological explosive at perspectives that he doesn't like, or not even doesn't like, he just thinks are wrong and are failing. And then he wants to retreat to things that he finds interesting that are more speculative.
他不必这样做。这可能就是他的观点的一部分，对吧？就像，我想斯洛特戴克想要通过以一种幽默且有时轻率的方式解构所有这些学科，就像他不太友善，他也不是特别严肃，然后嗯，他也不想直接参与批评或澄清他的立场，他只想抛出这种抽象的哲学，嗯，逻辑之类的东西。他向他不喜欢，或者甚至不是不喜欢，只是认为错误且正在失败的观点投掷了这种意识形态炸药。然后他想退回到他觉得有趣且更具推测性的事物中。
And like the, to me, like that kind of reminds me of Terrence McKenna, where Terrence McKenna was, you know, the psychonaut in the 70s. He was like wrong about almost everything. But one of the things that makes him still relevant or people like still into him is he was just so open to like any new idea and any new mode and way of being and any possibility like he was studying potentiality in a way that i think was liberating for a generation that was sort of gen xy and they didn't have a voice and um you know they weren't into derrida uh they wanted a more of an experiential thing and mckenna did that and i think slaughter duke is similar to mckenna in that he wants to just say like not this is what the future is but like this is what like it could be. And like, let's just talk about like the potential of where this thing can go.
就像，对我来说，那种感觉让我想起了特伦斯·麦肯纳，特伦斯·麦肯纳是，你知道，70年代的心理航行者。他几乎在所有事情上都错了。但他仍然相关或人们仍然喜欢他的原因之一是，他非常开放地接受任何新想法、任何新模式和存在方式以及任何可能性，就像他以一种我认为对X世代和Y世代那样的代际解放的方式研究潜能，他们没有声音，嗯，你知道，他们不喜欢德里达，他们想要一种更具体验性的东西，而麦肯纳做到了。我认为斯洛特戴克和麦肯纳相似，因为他只想说，不是这就是未来，而是这就是它可能的样子。而且，让我们谈谈这个东西可以去向的潜力。
And he also isn't interested in a way that I like at deconstructing. Like, here's a million reasons that Marxism doesn't work. And then here's a reason that liberal capital doesn't work. And here's let me explain to you the failure of these things. He just sort of takes it for granted that if you're reading it, you know, the stuff that's not working and then it has to be replaced or that it should be or that it could be. And he's not really making a case for like this bad. So this next thing, good. He's just talking about, yeah, you feel that it doesn't work. So let's just talk about the inevitability of change and where that might go um so he's he's a loose
而且他也不像我喜欢的那样对解构感兴趣。就像，这里有一百万个马克思主义行不通的原因。然后这里有一个自由资本行不通的原因。这里让我向你解释这些事情的失败。他只是认为，如果你在读它，你就知道那些行不通的东西，它必须被取代，或者它应该被取代，或者它可能被取代。他并没有真正为这种坏的辩护。所以接下来这个，好的。他只是在谈论，是的，你感觉到它行不通。所以让我们谈谈变革的必然性以及它可能去向哪里，嗯，所以他是一个松散的
writer you know it's uh he's he's making a net not a cloth and like this ambiguity is compounded um by like his tendency to be ironic or be to use hyperbole and rhetorical devices that challenge you know establish ways of thinking and push the boundaries of what is considered acceptable discourse. And he also, as a poach, is never like, I'm going to reduce this to nothing and take this to a logical extreme. And then I'm not, I'm not just going to like, take this thing apart. I'm going to, I'm going to not reduce it to some logical extreme and then reveal its inherent flaws. He's just like, yeah, these ideologies don't work. Like, look around, they don't. And here's, like, because they're dying, like, what might be coming.
作家，你知道，他是在织网，而不是织布。这种模糊性被他倾向于讽刺或使用夸张和修辞手段来挑战，你知道，既定的思维方式并推动被认为是可接受的话语的界限所加剧。而且他，作为一个诗人，从来没有说，我要把这个简化为虚无，并把它带到一个逻辑极端。然后我不是，我不仅仅是想要拆解这个东西。我不会把它简化为某种逻辑极端，然后揭示其内在缺陷。他只是说，是的，这些意识形态行不通。就像，环顾四周，它们确实不行。而且这里是，因为它们正在消亡，所以可能即将到来的是什么。
And a lot of times I think what might be coming is scary to him. Like, he doesn't have an answer, but he's saying that, like, we have to have one, so what will it be? A lot of the directions that history moves in are not good. And so, like, in that sense, I think his critique is more gestural, and he's, like, using provocative language and examples to draw attention to blind spots and things. But he's not really associated with any sort of ideology because his persona has to be, you know, deconstructing them.
很多时候，我认为即将到来的东西对他来说是可怕的。就像，他没有答案，但他是在说，我们必须有一个，所以它会是什么？历史发展的许多方向并不好。所以，在某种意义上，我认为他的批评更具姿态性，他使用挑衅性的语言和例子来引起人们对盲点和事物的注意。但他并没有真正与任何意识形态联系在一起，因为他的角色必须是，你知道，解构它们。
And so he'll say things that are like wildly right wing fascist left wing concepts. And then he draws a lot of controversy. Like, I don't know everything about him. And like, I'm not going to defend all of it, but I think there's an ideological ambiguity that also isn't avoidant, right? Like a lot of times when people are like, I'm afraid of conflict, so the truth is in the middle. Like he's not doing that. He's just being, I like this, I like that, I like this, I like that. And people are like, wait, those don't fit into a pile together.
所以他会说一些非常右翼、法西斯、左翼概念的话。然后他引起了很多争议。就像，我并不了解关于他的一切。而且我不会为所有这些辩护，但我认为有一种意识形态的模糊性，它也不是回避的，对吧？就像很多时候当人们说，我害怕冲突，所以真理在中间。他没有那样做。他只是在说，我喜欢这个，我喜欢那个，我喜欢这个，我喜欢那个。人们会说，等等，那些不能放在一起。
And he doesn't care. So, you know, that is interesting too. And I think the reason I'm talking about his persona is because I think it's part of the philosophy because that clashes with, you know, Germany, German culture of, um, you know, like it's known to be a very socially liberal place, um, and values that sort of like social liberality, but also deeply culturally entrenched, um, hierarchies and traditions and structure,
而他不在乎。所以，你知道，这也很有趣。我认为我谈论他的角色是因为我认为它是哲学的一部分，因为它与，你知道，德国，德国文化，嗯，你知道，它以一个非常社会自由的地方而闻名，嗯，并且重视那种社会自由，但也深深地在文化上根深蒂固，嗯，等级制度和传统和结构，
uh, that he's saying essentially like, isn't relevant or real or there are important or eternal in a way that if you've ever been to Germany, um, or, you know, if you,
嗯，他基本上是在说，这不相关或不真实，或者它们在某种程度上是重要的或永恒的，如果你去过德国，嗯，或者，你知道，如果你，
if you're familiar with German culture would upset a German and has a lot. Uh, so his critiques of society, I think, call for this radical rethinking of human experience. Um, they can be seen as a challenge or an invitation and therapy has to engage with these questions. I don't know where it goes. Like so much of this is about like, where's therapy not being relevant? Where does it go? I think Slaughter Deke is doing that with culture. Um, and remember psychotherapy is a point of culture. He's not terribly well read over here, but that's why I think he's important and relevant to this discussion, because the point of this is not for me to tell you where therapy is going, because I don't know.
如果你熟悉德国文化，会惹恼德国人，而且有很多。嗯，所以他对社会的批评，我认为呼吁对人类经验进行激进的重新思考。嗯，它们可以被视为一种挑战或邀请，治疗必须参与这些问题。我不知道它去向哪里。就像这其中很多是关于，治疗在哪里变得不相关？它去向哪里？我认为斯洛特戴克正在用文化做这件事。而且记住心理治疗是文化的一点。他在这里读得不多，但我认为这就是他重要且与这次讨论相关的原因，因为这点的目的不是让我告诉你治疗要去向哪里，因为我不知道。
It's to tell you the questions, like Plato, that psychotherapy has to address if it's going to stay relevant and if it's going to, like, keep its soul. If it's not just going to become this, like, external apparatus to the medical industry where medicine finds something inconvenient to do and punts it at a social worker. If it's going to be half art, half science in the way that I think it should be, the art and the science have to engage with the things that I've brought up in these four parts. I think. What why they tell you when you're writing an essay never say i think because if you're if you wrote it you thought it um i need
而是告诉你，像柏拉图一样，心理治疗如果想要保持相关性，如果它想要，嗯，保持它的灵魂，就必须解决的问题。如果它不仅仅是成为医疗行业的一个外部装置，医学发现一些不方便做的事情，然后把它踢给社会工作者。如果它要成为一半艺术，一半科学，就像我认为它应该的那样，艺术和科学必须参与我在前四部分中提出的事情。我想。为什么当你写论文时他们告诉你永远不要说“我想”，因为如果你写了它，你就想了它，嗯，我需要
a public speaking class but like for most of his career he was outside of the university and um he basically just sort of wrote himself into relevance because he wrote a 3 000 page book uh lit like literally it's a more than two it's like 2500 something pages um the spheres trilogy and uh there was a philosophical work that was thousands of pages and also sold really well which even germany is hard to do. And so academia sort of had to deal with them. And so the spheres, if you want to look at like, why did I bring that up? What relates these things to therapy is like, I think trauma is something that we could learn a lot from in these things.
一个公共演讲课，但就像他职业生涯的大部分时间都在大学之外，嗯，他基本上只是把自己写进了相关性，因为他写了一本3000页的书，嗯，字面上，它超过两本，它有2500多页，嗯，球体三部曲，嗯，那是一部数千页的哲学著作，而且卖得也很好，这在德国也很难做到。所以学术界不得不处理它们。所以球体，如果你想看看，为什么我提到了那个？什么将这些东西与治疗联系起来，就像，我认为创伤是我们可以在这些事情中学到很多的东西。
And that kind of lends to look at because look at how, you know, somebody doing the same psychoanalysis in the 50s, it no longer worked in the 70s because somebody was saying like, I'm black, I'm a woman, I'm this, and this isn't for me anymore. And then it had to change.
而且这有点倾向于看，因为看看，你知道，50年代做同样心理分析的人，在70年代不再起作用了，因为有人在说，我是黑人，我是女人，我是这个，这不再适合我了。然后它不得不改变。
Like, listen to those things in therapy because like what I see is so many people not wanting to engage with this world. And therapists who have been saying to sometimes the same patient for, like, seven years now, just wait until it goes back to normal. Just hang in there and it'll go. It's not going to go back to normal, right? Because, like, when has there been a normal and, like, when has history ever gone back to anything like we have to figure out where we're going which is partially an analysis and understanding of the world which i think is more of a felt sense than an intellectual analytical one
就像，在治疗中倾听这些事情，因为我看到的是很多人不想参与这个世界。还有那些已经对同一个病人说了七年，就像，等着它恢复正常。只要坚持住，它就会过去。它不会恢复正常，对吧？因为，就像，什么时候有过正常，而且，就像，历史什么时候回到过任何东西，我们必须弄清楚我们要去向哪里，这部分是对世界的分析和理解，我认为这比智力分析更是一种感觉。
and also what that means for the conception of self that our patients are coming in with and so like when trauma happens what does spheres have to do with trauma, right? Yeah. There's a traumatic event. I have PTSD. I have flashbacks to the PTSD. I want to get rid of the PTSD, you know, something like brain spotting or neurostem or whatever, like, you know, emotional transformation therapy, somatic experiencing, lifespan integration. Now I'm not having the nightmares. Now I don't feel bad, but all of a sudden the trauma is not gone. Can I still call it trauma?
还有这对我们的病人带来的自我概念意味着什么。所以，就像当创伤发生时，球体与创伤有什么关系，对吧？是的。有一个创伤性事件。我有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。我有PTSD的闪回。我想摆脱PTSD，你知道，像大脑定位或神经刺激或任何东西，像，你知道，情绪转化疗法，躯体体验，寿命整合。现在我没有噩梦了。现在我不觉得难受了，但突然间创伤并没有消失。我还能称之为创伤吗？
Because I don't feel good. And the reason that I don't feel good is that that experience made me know things about the world that I didn't want to know. I know I know them and I don't feel normal. Can you help me? I don't even know how to say what this problem is to my therapist. You know, and that could be Trump gets elected. I think that Trump is bad. I think that most people who are in my friends and family think that he's bad or the bad is bad, yet they are liking him or something. And then they're telling me all these things that they believe. And before that, I could just be like, well, Republicans and Democrats want the same thing. They just want to go about it a different way or whatever they told me in eighth grade. And then I'm sitting here and no, they don't. They want very different things. And I don't know how to reconcile that because I believe
因为我感觉不好。我感觉不好的原因是，那种经历让我知道了关于世界的事情，我不想知道。我知道我知道它们，而且我不觉得正常。你能帮我吗？我甚至不知道如何向我的治疗师说出这个问题是什么。你知道，那可能是特朗普当选。我认为特朗普很坏。我认为大多数在我的朋友和家人中认为他很坏，或者坏事很坏，但他们却喜欢他或什么的。然后他们告诉我所有他们相信的事情。在那之前，我可以只是说，嗯，共和党人和民主党人想要同样的东西。他们只是想以不同的方式去做，或者他们在八年级告诉我的任何事情。然后我坐在这里，不，他们没有。他们想要非常不同的东西。而且我不知道如何调和这一点，因为我相信
that I love my grandfather. I believe that all families have to get along in this way. Or I believe that the self is a monad. It's a single entity and it doesn't have multiple parts. And now I'm trying to decide, do I have to cancel Grandan? Or should I just be avoided and pretend that he doesn't say or think any of the things he says and thinks? You know, parts-based therapy can answer that by saying, okay, you can love this person and love their potential and love these parts of them. And you can say, I think you're running from something here.
我爱我的祖父。我相信所有的家庭都必须以这种方式相处。或者我相信自我是一个单子。它是一个单一的实体，它没有多个部分。现在我正在试图决定，我必须取消祖父吗？还是我应该只是避免并假装他没有说或想他所说和想的任何事情？你知道，基于部分的治疗可以通过说，好的，你可以爱这个人，爱他们的潜能，爱他们的这些部分来回答。你可以说，我认为你在这里逃避某些事情。
I don't think what you're doing is loving, not to these other people, but to these other people, because you don't love yourself in this one, whatever. That's an, that's an ability to engage with this process, right? Like most of the things that trauma digs up are not the direct effect it has. It's that it makes ourself change. And we don't want to change ourself because we want the old self back because we know how to be that one. And we don't have the option, right? Of like all believing the same
我不认为你在做的事情是爱，不是对这些人，而是对这些人，因为你在这个中不爱你自己，无论如何。这是一种参与这个过程的能力，对吧？就像创伤挖掘出的大多数东西不是它产生的直接影响。而是它使我们的自我改变了。我们不想改变我们的自我，因为我们想要旧的自我回来，因为我们知道如何成为那一个。而且我们没有选择，对吧？像所有人在政治上相信同样的事情
thing politically anymore. Like not having that anxiety, no matter what you believe, like we don't have it. Like if you're going off and you're going to die in world war one for the Kaiser and you know that you probably are going to die. Maybe you don't like that, but you know, like all of you are going off to do that because it's brave and it's noble and the Kaiser is there for a reason and like he's cool and this is the way the world works and we're all in this sphere. You don't have that ability now. You're either avoiding information about the people who run the world,
不再有了。就像没有那种焦虑，无论你相信什么，就像我们没有它。就像如果你要离开，你要为凯撒在第一次世界大战中死去，而且你知道你很可能会死。也许你不喜欢那样，但你知道，就像你们所有人都要去那样做，因为它是勇敢的，它是高尚的，凯撒在那里是有原因的，而且就像他很酷，这就是世界运作的方式，我们都在这个领域。你现在没有那种能力了。你要么在回避关于统治世界的人的信息，
or you are letting yourself know it. And either one is creating anxiety, because, like, there wasn't internet. There wasn't someone who had to go, yeah, I'm going to die in this conflict that's going to kill all these people and then the World War I is going to throw this huge existential snowball at philosophy and no one will know why anything exists anymore. But it's fine. I'm happy to do that because I'm reading on the Internet and the Kaiser is just this weird dude who should never have been in charge and isn't a good politician.
要么你正在让自己知道它。无论哪一个都在制造焦虑，因为，就像，没有互联网。没有一个人必须去，是的，我要死在这场将杀死所有这些人的冲突中，然后第一次世界大战将把这个巨大的存在主义雪球扔给哲学，没有人会知道为什么任何东西还存在。但这很好。我很高兴这样做，因为我在互联网上阅读，凯撒只是这个奇怪的家伙，他根本不应该负责，也不是一个好的政治家。
And he's obsessed with his mother's hands in a weird way and uh once you have that information you don't want to go die in world war one once the existential snowball like hits europe you can't go back and have world war one again you know you have to have world war two very different wars and it's not because technology changed it's because the spheres changed about why we did things and who we thought we were and and these cultural traumas do the same thing as individual traumas and where all of a sudden like i don't know who i am anymore and i think that that is something that has to be a part of where therapy goes. You know, you can see through the lies of society now, for the lack of a better word.
而且他以一种奇怪的方式沉迷于他母亲的手，嗯，一旦你有了那个信息，你就不想去第一次世界大战中死去，一旦存在主义雪球击中欧洲，你就不能回去再进行第一次世界大战了，你知道，你必须进行第二次世界大战，非常不同的战争，这不是因为技术改变了，而是因为领域改变了，关于我们为什么做事情以及我们认为我们是谁，而且这些文化创伤做了和个人创伤一样的事情，突然间，就像我不知道我是谁了，我认为这是必须成为治疗去向的一部分。你知道，你现在可以看穿社会的谎言，用一个更好的词来说。
And now what you're having is people have to accept too much and they have to understand too much. I didn't have to know how politics worked. I didn't have to watch CNN. I didn't have to have an opinion on the war, right? In Germany, like, I just went out and died. And while maybe that sucked, it wasn't complicated. Now it is. It's complicated to be alive. Like, if you think one of these sides of politics going on now, pick a side, doesn't have to be American, whatever. This one's good and an angel and that one's bad and it's a devil and this one wants to
现在你拥有的是人们必须接受太多，他们必须理解太多。我不必知道政治是如何运作的。我不必看CNN。我不必对战争有看法，对吧？在德国，就像，我只是出去死了。虽然也许那很糟糕，但并不复杂。现在是了。活着很复杂。就像，如果你认为现在正在进行的政治的一方，选一方，不必是美国的，无论什么。这一方是好的，是一个天使，而那一方是坏的，是一个恶魔，这一方想要
help me and that one wants to hurt me. No, like this is a bloody compromise and people are starting to realize that whether or not they admit it and it's making everyone incredibly anxious. And one of the ways of conceptualizing that anxiety is that there are all of these spheres. If you're a Democrat, if you're a Republican, or if you're whatever, you have to have an opinion on like 800 million issues, and I don't even overlap with the other people in my party or my church. Again, the Venn diagram used to be that everyone was in a circle, and then the circle became a Venn diagram, and then it became, you know, a Venn diagram with three, four, five, six, and now it's a foam. And like, how unlikely is it that I line up with anybody who believes these shared things? Is there a community that can transcend that thing that can overlap through those things?
帮助我，而那一方想要伤害我。不，就像这是一个血腥的妥协，人们开始意识到这一点，无论他们是否承认，这让每个人都非常焦虑。概念化这种焦虑的方法之一是存在所有这些领域。如果你是民主党人，如果你是共和党人，或者如果你是任何什么，你必须对像8亿个问题有看法，我甚至不与我党派或教会中的其他人重叠。再次，维恩图曾经是每个人都在一个圆圈里，然后圆圈变成了维恩图，然后它变成了，你知道，一个有三个、四个、五个、六个的维恩图，现在它是一个泡沫。而且，就像我与任何相信这些共享事物的人保持一致的可能性有多大？有没有一个社区可以超越那个东西，可以通过那些东西重叠？
You know, a definition of self that can do something like that. And also, you know, that kind of conception of trauma, like gives you a way into thinking about implicit memory. You know, that a lot of the things that we actually believe, we don't know we believe, you know, no, no, no, I'm not mad. I'm not mad. I'm not mad. I'm not mad. Stop asking me if I'm mad. I've had a hard day. I did all these things. I come home and I didn't want to do any of them. I stopped by the store for you. And now you're here asking me if I'm mad. Well, I think you were mad, man. Like, I think you just didn't know it. I mean, these are the, so many of the things that we're digging out of people to help them understand
你知道，一个可以做那种事情的自我定义。而且，你知道，那种创伤的概念，就像给你一种思考隐性记忆的方法。你知道，我们实际上相信的很多事情，我们不知道我们相信，你知道，不，不，不，我不生气。我不生气。我不生气。我不生气。别再问我是否生气了。我度过了艰难的一天。我做了所有这些事情。我回家了，我不想做任何事情。我为你顺便去了商店。现在你在这里问我是否生气。嗯，我想你生气了，伙计。就像，我想你只是不知道。我的意思是，这些是，我们从人们身上挖掘出来的很多东西，为了帮助他们理解
and deal with our emotions that we don't know we're feeling, you know, they're, they're not explicit, they're implied. And, and because of that, you know, implication, we don't always know the sphere that we're in. Implicit memory is encoded with the brain through these repeated experiences and interactions with the environment. It creates these neural networks and those associations operate automatically and without conscious effort. These memories from the basis of our habits and skills and our emotional responses they're all tied to these specific spheres and contexts you know i get excited when i hear communism or i get angry because communism's bad you know that relates to a kind of emotional encoding that we don't get at with logic. And, you know, for example, like a person
并处理我们不知道我们在感受的情绪，你知道，它们不是显性的，它们是隐含的。而且，因为那种暗示，我们并不总是知道我们所处的领域。隐性记忆是通过这些重复的经历和与环境的互动在脑中编码的。它创造了这些神经网络，这些关联自动运行，无需有意识的努力。这些记忆构成了我们习惯和技能以及情绪反应的基础，它们都与这些特定的领域和背景相关联，你知道，当我听到共产主义时我很兴奋，或者我很生气，因为共产主义很坏，你知道，这与一种我们无法用逻辑达到的情绪编码有关。而且，你知道，例如，像一个人
who grows up in a family sphere, that's got emotional neglect. I mean, they may have implicit memories of isolation and worth unworthiness. And why, why wasn't I special enough for somebody to notice me that shape their relationships and expectations when they're talking to somebody in a Walmart and they're not making eye contact and they're not doing this, you ask them if they're fine, but they don't know that the base of their brain is assuming all of these things because of the sphere of like what family and relationship is. And, you know, um, the, the, the idea of immunology is that there's this, that Slaughter, Decazes, this idea of idea of defense of a sphere that can be seen as, you know, analogous to the unconscious defenses of the psyche, that a lot of the ways that the
在家庭领域长大，有情感忽视。我的意思是，他们可能有孤立和不值得的隐性记忆。为什么，为什么我不够特别让某人注意到我，这塑造了他们的人际关系和期望，当他们和沃尔玛的人说话时，他们没有眼神交流，他们没有这样做，你问他们是否还好，但他们不知道他们大脑的基础正在假设所有这些事情，因为家庭和关系是什么的领域。而且，你知道，嗯，免疫学的想法是，有这个，斯洛特戴克有这个防御领域的想法，可以被视为，你知道，类似于心理的无意识防御，即很多方式，
sphere reacts defensively to attack or exclude people or neutralize perceived threats or try and like embrace and take over another sphere like a cell those are ego defenses right but their ego defenses played out at the societal level so you may hate slaughter deke's thing like you may choke on all that and be like why would you need this weird language and that's fine um you know not all of it is 100 for me um but what I'm trying to do is take a lot of different people who are feeling the same thing and then collect their languages and put them in these kind of verbal essays so that maybe somebody who's not geared to, you know, hear this as a Jungian perspective or something can kind of hear it and get into it. Um, but I think what therapy needs to be
领域防御性地反应以攻击或排除人或中和感知到的威胁或试图像细胞一样拥抱和接管另一个领域，那些是自我防御，对吧？但它们是在社会层面上演的自我防御。所以你可能讨厌斯洛特戴克的想法，就像你可能被所有这些噎住，并说为什么你需要这种奇怪的语言，那没关系，嗯，你知道，并不是所有这些都100%适合我，但我试图做的是带走很多感觉同样事情的不同人，然后收集他们的语言，把它们放在这些口头论文中，这样也许一个不倾向于，你知道，听到这是荣格视角或什么的某人可以听到它并进入它。嗯，但我认为治疗需要成为
is this kind of safe, supportive therapeutic sphere that is bigger. That just says like, you can go into these places where there is somebody who maybe like in the old world, a shaman used to be like, I'm not a huge advocate for returning all the way back to old school shamanism techniques. Some people do that. That's fine. I don't think that that's going to transform the profession, right? But in a modern way, like a shaman, these people are holding space for a bigger sphere where everyone is welcome, where you won't be judged, where they're not pretending that they know the answer, where they're not explaining all of these things to you, where they're just making room for yourself as you need to recontextualize it and reconceive of it and learn to self-reflect and self-regulate
这是一种更大、更安全、更具支持性的治疗领域。它就像是在说，你可以进入这些地方，那里有人——就像旧世界里的萨满一样——我并不是非常主张完全回归旧派萨满技术，有些人这样做，那没问题，我不认为这会改变这个职业。但在现代意义上，萨满式的人物为人们提供了一个更大的空间，每个人都受欢迎，不会被评判，他们不假装自己知道答案，不向你解释所有事情，只是为你留出空间，让你在需要重新构建、重新构想、学习自我反思和自我调节时使用。
and hear the music of the spheres, man, like all of these things conjuncting. I think that's the role. I hesitate to call that something like neo-shamanism or whatever and leak myself too much to that, but I think that there's an idea that this is a place that is a break that is outside time where you find you. It's something that therapy used to say better and louder and be associated more with. And we've turned it into something that is more practical and empirical and transactional that it always, it will never get away from those things entirely. Um, but that we've made them the point, uh, we've let them take over the sphere of mental health as we conceive of it and its goals too much so one of the things that's
去聆听天体音乐，伙计，就像所有这些事物的结合。我认为这就是角色所在。我不太愿意称之为新萨满教之类的东西，也不想让自己与此联系太紧密，但我认为有一种观念，即这是一个休息的地方，一个超越时间的地方，在那里你可以找到自己。这曾经是心理治疗更好地表达、更响亮地宣扬并与之更多关联的东西。而我们已经把它变成了一种更实用、更经验主义、更交易性的东西，虽然它永远无法完全摆脱这些，但我们已经把它们变成了重点，我们让它们占据了我们所构想的心理健康领域及其目标，这太多了，所以其中一件事是
kind of interesting about slaughter duke too is that like he criticizes that the past generation especially of like lefty leaning philosophers have been really good about diagnosing like all of the problems and directions that society is going but they have no solutions to make it go back. They're criticizing things, but they haven't really built a path towards anything, even like a blueprint. And you could say the same thing about him because he shies away from kind of a concrete vision of the future or even like a concrete vision of the past. Uh, but he does have these ideas for how to reduce the anxiety of the foam, you know, and like a way according to his ideology. And a lot of those things I think are relevant to psychotherapy.
关于斯洛特戴克（Sloterdijk）的有趣之处在于，他批评上一代人，特别是左倾哲学家，他们非常擅长诊断社会所面临的所有问题和发展方向，但他们没有解决办法让它回归。他们在批评事物，但并没有真正建立起通往任何事物的路径，甚至连蓝图都没有。你也可以对他这么说，因为他回避了对未来的具体愿景，甚至回避了对过去的具体愿景。但他确实有一些关于如何减少泡沫焦虑的想法，你知道，按照他的意识形态。我认为其中许多想法与心理治疗是相关的。
And one of them is that he says we have to reconnect with this maternal sphere and remember, you know, and it can be a spiritual vision for you. It can be a part of your faith. It can also be, I think, cultivated in a secular space where you say, let's go back to the place where we were in the womb, um, where we had like nurturing intimacy and this sense of belonging in a world that feels fragmented and disconnected um we can cultivate this healthier sense of space and relationship and we need a place where there's kind of like safety and comfort and where the tension from the foam turns off and we're just back with the one we also like have to reinterpret i think the way that or you know he says the way that the metaphysical sphere operates like the the traditional metaphysical sphere may no longer
其中之一是他认为我们必须与这个母性领域重新连接并铭记，你知道，这可以是你的一种精神愿景。它可以是你信仰的一部分。我认为它也可以在世俗空间中培养，你说，让我们回到我们在子宫里的地方，那里有滋养的亲密感，在这个感觉支离破碎和脱节的世界里有一种归属感。我们可以培养这种更健康的领域感和关系感，我们需要一个有安全感和舒适感的地方，让泡沫带来的紧张感消失，我们只是回到那个“一”。我认为我们还必须重新诠释他所说的形而上学领域的运作方式，传统的形而上学领域可能不再
be relevant um and we can still find meaning and purpose by engaging with art culture and philosophy as new spheres but we have something that doesn't really celebrate like art and culture and philosophy anymore. Like our culture largely is faced based around what people can create. And a lot of the community spaces or artistic practices that we had like went away after COVID, um, you know, digitally, analogically, he he's suggesting pathways, but he doesn't have kind of practical ways that you could do that. But those, there needs to be some reconnection with a larger whole, I think is the broader point of what he's saying and maybe the broader point of what I'm asking psychotherapy to do. And so navigating that foam, you know, one of the things he says is that the modern world is characterized by all these spaces, networks, identities.
相关了。我们仍然可以通过参与艺术、文化和哲学作为新的领域来寻找意义和目的，但我们现在所拥有的东西并不真正推崇艺术、文化和哲学。我们的文化很大程度上是基于人们能创造什么。我们在新冠疫情后失去许多社区空间或艺术实践，你知道，无论是数字上还是模拟上，他提出了路径，但他没有提供你可以实践的具体方法。但我认为他所说的更广泛的观点是需要与一个更大的整体重新连接，也许这也是我要求心理治疗所做的事情。所以，驾驭那个泡沫，你知道，他所说的一点是，现代世界是由所有这些空间、网络、身份所构成的。
But to have a healthier sense of self, we need to learn to navigate the spheres and find meaningful connections. That we have to kind of hop between them or make them blur together a little bit more. And find some kind of coherence, even though the world is fragmented, that makes living in multiple spheres, cause that's not going to go away, makes sense to us. And we have to harness the potential or make that be less fragmenting. Um, he sees, he's not afraid of technology. Um, he sees a lot more potential digitally, even like weird avenues of like that, that i don't really see is like relevant to psychotherapy or possible of like he sees like genetic engineering or cybernetically linking brains together or something it's some way of creating some new thing i think that is more of
但为了拥有更健康的自我感，我们需要学会驾驭这些领域并找到有意义的联系。我们必须在它们之间跳跃，或者让它们融合得更多一点。即使世界是碎片化的，也要找到某种连贯性，这使得生活在多个领域中——因为这种情况不会消失——对我们来说是有意义的。我们必须利用这种潜力，或者让它减少碎片化。他不害怕技术，他在数字领域看到了更多的潜力，甚至是一些奇怪的途径，我并不认为这与心理治疗相关或可行，比如他看到的基因工程或通过控制论将大脑连接在一起，或者某种创造新事物的方式，我认为这更多是
a meditation on possibility for me that's where that works i don't see those digital tools as something you can do but like he's he's not afraid of them. Um, and then the bigger idea of making immunity somehow, you know, maybe psychotherapy's role is to make immunity, you know, and he argues that, you know, in a world where there's global risk and uncertainty, we have to develop that sense of immunity, not just in the biological sense, but also in our ability to like adapt and create boundaries and maintain a sense of immunity not just in the biological sense but also in our ability to like adapt and create boundaries and maintain a sense of identity in the middle of change one of the reason the self is so hard to navigate is because the world is changing so fast
一种对可能性的冥想，对我来说这就是它的作用。我不认为那些数字工具是你现在能做的，但他并不害怕它们。还有一个更大的想法，即以某种方式建立免疫力，你知道，也许心理治疗的作用是建立免疫力，他认为，在一个全球充满风险和不确定性的世界里，我们必须发展这种免疫感，不仅是在生物学意义上，而且是在我们适应、创造边界以及在变化中保持身份感的能力方面。自我之所以难以驾驭，原因之一就是世界变化太快了。
i mean there used to be like you could spot 20 year culture cycles cycles, and then you get up to the 50s, 40s, well, I guess maybe the 20s. But things start changing really noticeably every 10 years. Now it's like things are different in two months. Style, not just like the news cycle. I mean, like, style is moving at light speed, you know? Like, aesthetic things that used to take a long time to change. And we have to find some kind of permanence.
我的意思是，过去你可以发现20年的文化周期，然后到了50年代、40年代，好吧，我想也许是20年代。但事情开始每10年就有非常明显的改变。现在就像两个月内事情就不同了。风格，不仅仅是新闻周期。我的意思是，风格正以光速移动，你知道吗？比如，过去需要很长时间才能改变的审美事物。我们必须找到某种永恒性。
I think we have to find something that doesn't because that pace of culture is probably not going to slow down. And psychotherapy as it moves forward has to be in conversation with that need for stillness. I think more than it is now But you know self is a dialectic process and it emphasizes One thing and then it downplays another and then it downplays what it was just emphasizing. And the parts of self disagree. The self will primarily be this dialogue between an inner world that is just us. But is sort of unexpressible. And unshareable in a way that is isolating and upsetting. and then also this external world and in that external world
我认为我们必须找到某种不会改变的东西，因为那种文化节奏可能不会放慢。心理治疗在向前发展时，必须与那种对宁静的需求进行对话。我认为这比现在更重要。但你知道，自我是一个辩证的过程，它强调一件事，然后淡化另一件事，然后又淡化它刚刚强调的东西。自我的各个部分是不一致的。自我主要将是仅仅属于我们自己的内心世界与外部世界之间的对话，但这种内心世界在某种程度上是无法表达、无法分享的，这令人感到孤立和不安。而在那个外部世界中，
um we are sort of irrelevant in a way that we don't want to be you know so much of these like neuroses and false quests for immortality building pyramids or hoarding wealth or whatever uh hoarding anything really i think becomes this like need to last more than we can in the external world. You know, um, Robert Pogue Harrison says in his book that like the site of ruins is upsetting and evocative. And like, we put that on places of contemplation, just like an old Greek temple with like Ivy on it and light streaming through, because it makes us remember that no matter, not just that it makes us remember that no matter not just that we die but that no matter what we do no matter what we build it will just kind of be
我们以一种我们不想要的方式变得无关紧要。你知道，这么多神经症和对不朽的虚假追求，建造金字塔或囤积财富，或者任何东西，囤积任何东西，我认为都变成了这种需要，即在外部世界中比我们实际能存在的时间更长。你知道，罗伯特·波格·哈里森（Robert Pogue Harrison）在他的书中说，废墟的景象是令人不安和引人深思的。我们把这种景象放在沉思的地方，就像一座长满常春藤、光线穿透的古希腊神庙，因为它让我们记住，不仅仅是让我们记住我们终将死亡，而是无论我们做什么，无论我们建造什么，它最终都会被
eaten by the earth in a way that makes us reflect and also makes us calm and there may be something about an awareness and a relationship with death and impermanence that becomes the thing that therapy needs to embrace that can give us a sense of permanence, there might be something there. But when we focus too heavily on this inner world, we risk losing the sight of the important role that both worlds play, that the outside world affects the inner world, the self is affected by the world that it inhabits. And if we become overly absorbed in our inner world, we become disconnected from the reality of our surroundings and the basic necessities of life, where we feel like we have magical powers in an external sense that
被大地吞噬，这让我们反思，也让我们平静。对死亡和无常的觉知与关系，可能正是治疗需要拥抱的东西，这能给我们一种永恒感，这可能是有道理的。但当我们过于关注这个内心世界时，我们就有可能忽视这两个世界所扮演的重要角色，即外部世界影响内心世界，自我受到它所居住的世界的影响。如果我们过度沉浸在内心世界中，我们就会与周围的现实和生活的基本必需品脱节，我们会觉得自己在外部意义上拥有某种魔法力量，而
our ego inflation are not real. I think the key to a healthy and authentic self is this ability to engage in the dialectical process of being aware of the waxing and waning and the transitions of kind of who you are. It's not getting somewhere. It's not scratching symptoms off a list. It's not even feeling a certain way. It's a sort of presentness that is very hard to articulate. And it's an awareness that is very hard to explain. And I don't know. So to wrap up, there's the philosopher A, the, um, philosopher Ayn Rand. This might be apocryphal, but I've heard it, a different version of it from a couple of people who kind of fell out with her at the end of her life. She died, um, in the eighties and, uh, she was, had kind of fell out with almost everybody.
我们的自我膨胀是不真实的。我认为健康和真实自我的关键在于这种参与辩证过程的能力，即意识到你作为一个人的盈亏和转变。这不是为了达到某个目标。不是在清单上划掉症状。甚至不是为了感觉某种特定的方式。这是一种很难表达的临在感。这是一种很难解释的觉知。我不知道。所以总结一下，有哲学家安·兰德（Ayn Rand）。这可能是杜撰的，但我从几个在她生命末期与她闹翻的人那里听到了不同的版本。她死于八十年代，她几乎和所有人都闹翻了。
Um, but when she was older, there is like a quote that has been shared a couple times that i've heard where people would ask her in an interview or privately in a qa or something or you know in a qa or privately or whatever like you know you have all these ideas about politics and objectivism and they've had this big effect on the world and silicon valley's a thing and the government's very right-wing and like what do you like what do you uh think about that um you know how do you feel about the fact that when you die there'll be this legacy you left behind that a lot of people are saying is not good or it's controversial whatever and what she said was some variant of when when I die, there is no world.
但当她年老时，有几个人分享过一句引语，我听说过，人们会在采访中或私下的问答环节中问她，你知道，你对政治和客观主义有所有这些想法，它们对世界产生了巨大的影响，硅谷是一个现象，政府非常右翼，你对此有什么看法？你知道，当你死后，你留下的遗产被很多人说是不好的，或者是有争议的，等等，你对此有什么感觉？她说的是某种变体：当我死时，世界就不存在了。
Or when I die, the world will go away with me. Because I think when you were a purely objectivist like Ayn Rand was, you mistake the subject for the object. And when Ayn Rand says that she will work for no other man's happiness and no other man can work for hers, I mean, she means more than politics there. She means that she is fundamentally alone and that there's probably a clue early in her, one of her journals, she says that she wanted to call objectivism realism, but then she realized that realism was already taken and associated with all this stuff that she hated and didn't think was quote unquote real. And I think there's a clue there because fundamentally Ayn Rand thought that she was the only thing that was real. And the subject agency, you know, of ego self was so overpowering that no one else had a right to soul. No one else really existed
或者当我死时，世界将随我而去。因为我认为当你像安·兰德那样是一个纯粹的客观主义者时，你会把主体误认为客体。当安·兰德说她不会为任何其他人的幸福而工作，也没有人能为她的幸福而工作时，我的意思是，她不仅仅是指政治。她是说她从根本上是孤独的，而且在她的日记早期可能有一个线索，她说她想把客观主义称为现实主义，但后来她意识到现实主义已经被占用了，并与她所憎恨的所有东西联系在一起，她认为那些东西不是所谓的“真实”。我认为那里有一个线索，因为从根本上说，安·兰德认为她是唯一真实的东西。主体的能动性，你知道，自我意识是如此强大，以至于没有其他人有权拥有灵魂。没有其他人真正存在，
unless they were aligned with her fundamental self interest, which was the only sphere that she inhabited. Even if they were lovers and friends or students or successors. These people were just kind of tools for your rational self-interest. And so sometimes they overlapped with yours, but ultimately it was just that. It was just a temporary alignment of each individual moving towards a rational self-interest. And when you die, that rational self-interest ends. And it has no more need for a relationship with a world that never really, you know, was you anyway. That clip at the beginning was James Dickey
除非他们与她根本的自身利益保持一致，这是她居住的唯一领域。即使他们是爱人、朋友、学生或继任者。这些人只是你理性自身利益的工具。所以有时他们与你的利益重叠，但最终也仅此而已。这只是每个个体走向理性自身利益的暂时一致。当你死时，那种理性自身利益就结束了。它不再需要与一个从未真正是你自己的世界建立关系。开头的那段剪辑是詹姆斯·迪基（James Dickey），
the author who wrote Deliverance and several other things talking about poetry with Robert Penn Warren Penn Warren wrote the last poem that I closed the series with I'm going to read one more by him to close this one. His stuff is hard to find. The stuff that isn't digitally available is kind of lost. You
写了《激流四勇士》（Deliverance）和其他几部作品的作者，他与罗伯特·潘·沃伦（Robert Penn Warren）谈论诗歌。潘·沃伦写了我结束本系列所用的最后一首诗。我打算再读一首他的诗来结束这一期。他的作品很难找到。那些没有数字化的作品基本上已经丢失了。你
can't really get his books. You know, if you find books of his poetry, they're usually pretty expensive. I used to have some that I've lost, unfortunately. But this one is called A Way to Love God. And that clip from Dickie and Penn Warren talking comes from YouTube. And it's funny, they had these conversations and it was you know pretty much at the end of dickie's life and warren lived a little bit longer but dickie drank himself to death um he actually died right after he spoke at swanee which was my school i mean i didn't see him or anything i was a kid but um that was the last thing he did and they had an interesting chemistry that i think got at something
真的买不到他的书。你知道，如果你找到他的诗集，通常都很贵。我过去有一些，不幸的是丢了。但这首诗叫《爱上帝的一种方式》。迪基和潘·沃伦谈话的那段剪辑来自YouTube。很有趣，他们进行了这些对话，那基本上是在迪基生命的尽头，沃伦活得稍微长一点，但迪基酗酒而死。他实际上是在塞瓦尼（Sewanee）演讲后就去世了，那是我的学校。我的意思是，我没有见到他或什么的，我当时还是个孩子，但那是他做的最后一件事。他们有一种有趣的化学反应，我认为这触及了
that I was trying to say with this. But here's Penn Warren, A Way to Love God. Here's the shadow of truth, for only the shadow is true, and the line where the incoming swell from the sunset Pacific first leans and staggers to break will tell all you need to know about submarine geography and your father's death rattle. Provides all biographical data required for the who's who of the dead. And I cannot recall what I started to tell you, but at least I can say how night long I have lain under the stars and heard mountains moan in their sleep.
我试图用这个表达的东西。但这是潘·沃伦的《爱上帝的一种方式》。这是真理的阴影，因为只有阴影是真实的，从日落太平洋涌来的浪潮第一次倾斜并蹒跚破碎的线条，将告诉你关于海底地理和你父亲临终喉音所需知道的一切。提供了死者名人录所需的所有传记数据。我不记得我开始要告诉你什么了，但至少我可以告诉你，我在星空下躺了多久，听着群山在睡梦中呻吟。
By daylight, they remember nothing and they go about their lawful occasions or not going anywhere except in slow disintegration at night. They remember, however, there is something they cannot remember. So moan. Theirs is the perfect pain of conscience, that of forgetting the crime. And I hope you have not suffered it. I have. I do not recall what had burdened my tongue, but I urge you to think on the slug's white belly how slick and soft. On the hairless star's silver, silver while the silence blows like wind. And on the sea's virgin bosom unveiled to give suck to the wavering serpent of the moon.
白天，它们什么都不记得，它们继续做着合法的事务，或者除了缓慢的解体外哪里也不去。然而在晚上，它们记得，有些东西它们无法记住。所以呻吟。它们拥有完美的良心痛苦，即忘记了罪行的痛苦。我希望你没有遭受过这种痛苦。我有。我不记得是什么压在我的舌头上，但我敦促你思考蛞蝓白色的腹部是多么光滑柔软。思考无毛恒星的银色，当寂静像风一样吹过时。以及大海未被揭开的处女胸怀，为月亮摇曳的蛇提供乳汁。
And in the distance in plaza, piazza, place, plats, and square, boot heels like history being born on cobbles bang, everything seems an echo of something else. And when, by the hair, the headsman held up the head of Mary of Scots, the lips kept moving but without sound. The lips, they were trying to say something very important. But I had forgotten to mention an upland of wind-tortured stone, white in darkness and tall. But when no wind mist gathers, and once on the saray at night, midnight, I watched the sheep huddling, their eyes
在远处的广场、空地、平地和广场上，靴子后跟像历史在鹅卵石上诞生一样砰砰作响，一切似乎都是其他事物的回声。当刽子手提着苏格兰玛丽女王的头颅时，嘴唇还在动，但没有声音。嘴唇，它们试图说出非常重要的事情。但我忘了提到一片被风折磨的石头高地，在黑暗中洁白而高耸。但当没有风雾聚集时，有一次在深夜的露台上，我看着羊群挤在一起，它们的眼睛
stared into nothingness, and in the mist-diffused light their eyes were stupid and round like the eyes of fat fish in muddy water, or of a scholar who has lost the faith in his calling and their jaws did not move. Shreds of dry grass, gray in the gray mist, light hung from the side of a jaw, unmoving. You would think that nothing would ever happen. That may be a way to love God. And this time, this point, I will not explain. This one I wrote to Red Warren and dedicate to him. He writes wonderfully about hawks. His totem bird, the thing overhead, you know, in wings, is the hawk. Mine is the buzzard. And so this is about going with your friend and climbing a mountain in North Georgia.
盯着虚无，在雾气弥漫的光线下，它们的眼睛愚蠢而圆，就像浑水中肥鱼的眼睛，或者一个对自己的使命失去信仰的学者的眼睛，它们的下颚没有动。干草的碎片，在灰色的雾中呈现灰色，挂在下颚的一侧，一动不动。你会认为什么都不会发生。那可能是一种爱上帝的方式。这一次，这一点，我不会解释。这一首是我写给红沃伦（Red Warren）并献给他的。他写鹰写得非常棒。他的图腾鸟，头顶上的东西，你知道，在翅膀里，是鹰。我的是秃鹫。所以这是关于和你的朋友一起去爬北乔治亚州的一座山。
This is a place near Hogback Ridge. And the friend, impersonated by Mr. Warren, this never happened, but it's gonna, you know, has some beer because he likes to, you know, drink beer. And I do too, but I can't drink it because I'm sick, you see. And I'm on these diets and all that stuff, and I gotta keep my blood sugar at a certain level and all that stuff, you know. And it's about that, and it's about that and
这是一个靠近霍格巴克岭（Hogback Ridge）的地方。那个朋友，由沃伦先生扮演，这从未发生过，但你知道，他喝了一些啤酒，因为他喜欢，你知道，喝啤酒。我也喜欢，但我不能喝，因为我生病了，你明白吗。我正在节食，所有这些东西，我必须把血糖保持在一定水平，所有这些东西，你知道。就是关于那个，就是关于那个，以及
it's about the throwing out the window of all of that medical business you know and just doing what's right you know what you want to do you know well you know whether the buzzards come or not this is called under buzzards dedicated dedicated to Robert Penn Warren and it goes like this heavy summer heavy companion if we climb our mortal bodies high with great effort we shall find ourselves flying with the life of the birds of death. We have come up under buzzards. They face us slowly, slowly circling, and as we watch them, they turn us around, and you and I spin slowly, slowly rounding out the hill. We are level exactly on this moment, exactly on the same bird plane with those deaths they are the salvation of our sense of glorious movement brother it is right for us to face them every which way and come to ourselves and come from every
就是关于把所有那些医疗事务扔出窗外，你知道，只做正确的事，你知道你想做的事，你知道，无论秃鹫来不来。这首诗叫《在秃鹫之下》，献给罗伯特·潘·沃伦，它是这样的：沉重的夏天，沉重的同伴，如果我们费力地攀登我们凡人的身体，我们将发现自己正与死亡之鸟的生命一起飞翔。我们来到了秃鹫之下。它们面对着我们，缓慢地、缓慢地盘旋，当我们注视它们时，它们让我们转身，你和我缓慢地、缓慢地绕着山丘旋转。我们正处于这一刻的水平面上，与那些死亡处于完全相同的鸟类平面上，它们是我们辉煌运动感的救赎，兄弟，我们面对它们并来到我们自己身边，从每一个方向而来是正确的，
direction there is whirl and stand fast whence cometh death, O Lord? On the downwind riding fire of Hogback Ridge. But listen, what is dead here, they are not falling, but waiting, but waiting, riding. And they may know the rotten, nervous sweetness of my blood. Somewhere riding the updraft of a far forest fire, they sensed the city sugar the doctors found in time. My eyes are green as lettuce with my diet. My weight is down, one pocket nailed with needles and injections, the other dragging with sugar cubes to balance me in life and hold my blood level, level. Tell me, black riders, does this do any good? Tell me what I need to know about my time in the world.
旋转并站稳，死亡从何而来，主啊？在霍格巴克岭顺风骑行的火焰上。但听着，这里有什么是死的，它们没有坠落，而是在等待，在等待，骑行。它们可能知道我血液中腐烂、紧张的甜味。在远方森林大火的上升气流中，它们感觉到了医生及时发现的城市糖分。我的眼睛像生菜一样绿，因为我在节食。我的体重下降了，一个口袋里钉着针头和注射器，另一个口袋里拖着方糖来平衡我的生活，保持我的血糖水平，水平。告诉我，黑色的骑手，这有什么用吗？告诉我关于我在世间的时间，我需要知道什么。
Oh, out of the fiery furnace of pine woods, in the sap smoke and crown fire of needles, say when I'll die, when will the sugar rise boiling against me and my brain be sweetened to death? In heavy summer, like this day. All right, physicians, witness. I will shoot my veins full of insulin.
哦，从松树林的火炉中，在树脂烟雾和针叶的冠火中，告诉我我什么时候会死，糖分什么时候会沸腾起来对抗我，我的大脑什么时候会被甜死？在沉重的夏天，就像今天这样。好吧，医生们，见证吧。我要把胰岛素射满我的静脉。
Let the needle burn in. From your terrible heads the flight blood drains and you are falling back, back to the body raising fire. Heavy summer, heavy. My blood is clear for a time. Is it too clear? Heat waves are rising without birds, but something is gone from me, friend. This is too sensible. Really, it is better to know when to die, better for my blood to stream with the death wish of birds. You know, I had just as soon crushed this doomed syringe between two mountain rocks and bury this needle in needles of trees. Companion, open that bill. How the body works, how hard it works for its medical books is not everything. Everything is how much glory is in it. Heavy summer is right for a long drink of beer.
让针头燃烧进去。从你们可怕的头颅中，飞行之血流出，你们正在坠落，回到身体升起的火焰中。沉重的夏天，沉重的。我的血暂时清澈了。是不是太清澈了？热浪在没有鸟儿的情况下升起，但有些东西从我身上消失了，朋友。这太理智了。真的，最好知道什么时候死，最好让我的血液流淌着鸟儿的死亡愿望。你知道，我宁愿在两块山石之间压碎这支注定失败的注射器，把这根针埋在树木的针叶里。同伴，打开那瓶啤酒。身体如何工作，它为医学书籍工作得多么努力，这并不是一切。一切都在于其中有多少荣耀。沉重的夏天适合喝一大杯啤酒。
Red sugar of my eyeballs feels them turn blindly in the fire, rising, turning, turning back to Hogback Ridge, and it is all delicious, brother. My body is turning, is flashing unbalanced sweetness everywhere, and I am calling my birds. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我眼球的红色糖分感觉到它们在火焰中盲目地转动，升起，转动，转回霍格巴克岭，这一切都很美味，兄弟。我的身体正在转动，正在闪烁着不平衡的甜味，我正在呼唤我的鸟儿。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。